national master teddy coleman taking on
international master lars oscar hogg in the
i'm not gm speed chess championship hope you're
enjoying your weekend having a good day ready
for some exciting chess because we have that in
store for you and just a reminder to everybody you
may be new here but you are perfectly welcome
this is the format it is a single elimination
knockout we started with 16 players now we're
into the quarterfinals each match has the time
controls you see in front of you 75 minutes of
the longest time patrol of five minute plus one
second increment blitz we get 45 minutes of
the three plus one finally get 25 minutes of
everybody's favorite time patrol bullet chess and
the winner moves on the loser well they take their
prize money and they call it a fun tournament and
that prize money you see right in front of you
here we're in the quarterfinal stage so the winner
gets 300 and moves on the rest of the price on 300
is split by win percentage so every single game
counts in this format you don't want to take a
game off because that could cost you some prize
money and let's look at the overall bracket remind
everybody how we got here where we're going
you see that we are in the bottom right of our
bracket here teddy coleman lars oscar how lars
beat the 2020 runner-up elena kashlinskaya in a
very topsy-turvy day it was looking good for alina
at some points then lars he put up great defense
he was bending but not breaking and he was able
to win by the score 15-9 and for teddy coleman
against carissa gibb that was our closest match
of the first round he wins by a single point there
are plenty of games where look like carissa had
the upper hand teddy fought back valiantly and he
was able to win some games in mutual time trouble
and thus move on to the quarterfinals so we have
teddy we have lars oscar here it's going to be a
great matchup indeed of two very strong players
different styles and we'll see if they'll be
able to fix the mistakes they made in their first
matches where lars some of his openings did not
go his way that's what he said in the post-match
interview he was talking about it saying i
gotta work on my openings because alina was just
giving me problems in every single which way
and for teddy his openings looked very strong
but there were times where it felt like he lost
the threat of the position sometimes the tactics
were there he played something that was slightly
wrong and he was able to come back within the
match but it gave carissa many opportunities
and she did have so many good positions
and well this match is about to begin we want to
remind you of an upcoming match as well because
i know a lot of you are looking forward to that
one that will be international master levy rosman
better known as gotham chess to many of you out
there and international master eric rosen known
as i am rosen pretty straightforward and that will
be tuesday february 9th 6 p.m pacific time that's
9 p.m on the east coast here and well if you're
in europe that's pretty late so i don't know if
you're going to be staying up for that or early in
the morning i should say but that will be a great
finish to our quarterfinals here in
the i'm not gm speed chess championship
so we have just a few minutes until the match
begins i just saw you missed it because we put
him back on camera a second too late there lars
oscar was stretching he's getting ready for this
intense matchup it is intense these players they
stress we saw teddy in match one he was there just
fidgeting throughout the whole way and we'll
see if he can calm his nerves and play a good
match against lars because lars is here to play
he is one of the highest rated players in terms
of feed rating in the entire field and if he can
fix his opening woes that will give his chances a
much bigger boost than uh you know we have seen in
previous matches so lars he knows his work is cut
out for him teddy is the underdog in this match
he knows what he needs to fix and now it's about
putting all that hard work onto the chessboard so
just a minute away looking forward to this match
beginning here and i don't know what else to say i
kind of want their play to do the talking i speak
a lot i've done many of these shows but at the
end of the day it's what the players bring and for
teddy for lars oscar here we are going to see if
they have brought their best stuff on this sunday
and i see you all welcome everybody if you're
new this is the i'm not gm speech championship
and if you're returning you know exactly
what this is you don't need me to inform you
of what we're doing here and we have liftoff we
do have moves here teddy gets the white pieces
in game one you look at their blitz ratings it
is not that big of a difference 40 rating points
that's pretty close we see d4 and c4 by teddy and
look at that a strike with c5 and we get a benko
gambit so in lars style he's sacrificing a pawn
to open up the state of the board and you'll see
that there's this tension on a6 and b5 neither
side flinching just yet because if you take on
a6 that allows black's piece to take right back
in one turn but by playing a4 knight c3 bishop
f1 you know that this b5 pawn is well defended so
if it's captured you can capture right back and
probably with the bishop so you get to develop
in one turn it's a good lesson in tension here
and d6 knight f3 teddy playing this very quickly
and the b5 capture still bishop takes b5 so if
you are going to take on b5 you might want to wait
until this bishop makes a move because if i play
bishop e2 and then have to take well black gets a
move in the process so for lars you have to figure
out what that move should be are you going to put
your bishop on g4 and pin the knight are you going
to play with rookie 8 and try to play for e6 and
said lars plays bishop to b7 which stares into a
brick wall we see these pawn chain here limiting
the scope of that bishop but a timely e6 can break
the board open and that bishop can actually thrive
when that move is played so bishop e2 played by
teddy now i expect that's this capture to happen
because the bishop had to stop and then would
capture so it costs quite a tempo but what would
still be upon the head and of course we mentioned
this move e6 we should point out every single
turn that is a possibility that lars goes for
but the problem with playing e6 is if you capture
and you capture back at some point a knight g5
type of move will put pressure on this pawn on
e6 and teddy says to heck with that your bishop
on b7 will not be a strong piece i'm not taking
on e6 if you take me i take back your bishop is
staring into my pawn which is well defended by
this knight on c3 so that is the theme of this
position thus far for lars he wants to develop his
knight can't do that you drop e6 and then d6 so
if he is going to develop the knight it's going to
only be after he settles the tension in the center
he brings knight to a6 rather than d7 i guess
there's this b4 square pretty juicy one for
that knight and once it gets to b4 that d5 pawn
is under attack a third time three minor pieces
going right after that pawn so we see here that
teddy is sitting and thinking the knight can also
retreat to c7 but it's a less aggressive play so
it does attack the bishop it does attack the pawn
but the bishop can slide back to c4 to defend
this pawn on d5 which is why knight b4 seems to
accomplish more and right now teddy smartly trying
to figure out do i develop my bishop out to a
square like f4 here go after this d6 bond do i put
my bishop to g5 pinning your knight to the queen
but do i really want to take your knight with my
bishop i don't think so this bishop on g7 is a
very powerful piece and so if you have to capture
on f6 and say the queen captures back that's a
really nice diagonal for the queen and bishop
to be in line on so if h6 is played i think
teddy will more likely drop the bishop back
to a score like g3 rather than trading on f6
and knight b4 right after this pawn
but can you take it the answer for now
is no because of this pin so let's say i make
a move like rook to b1 and you try to take
i take you take and i can take on f6 and your
queen is under attack and so you actually can
get away with this just for the moment because
you can take mine knight and f3 but that's the
kind of tactic that lars has to be careful for is
that this pawn d5 you want to capture it so badly
but it could actually cost you some material
so queen d2 setting this exact thing up here
is now if you take i can take back and once you
try to take on f3 guess what there's no queen
on the d1 square so this would actually cost black
a full piece right away so lars will not be taking
on d5 he also can't really play h6 because the
queen and the bishop are lined up on that square
so typically against the fianchetto you want
to try to trade off that bishop in front of
the black king and here if you play h6 i steal
a pawn in the process so that could be a worthy
trade of pawns what do you mean by trade well h6
you give this h pawn and then you get this d5 pawn
and that could be nice for black especially with
this bishop on b7 but that's an important pawn in
front of your king so you have to be sure about
that before you go ahead and play move like h6
the bad news for black you can't play rook to e8
the bishop covers that square so this rook is sort
of stuck in place for now so what are we going to
do d5 can't be captured at least not yet where's
this rook going rook b8 no rook c8 no not really
accomplishing all that much so coming up with a
good move here for black isn't that easy another
move i'm thinking about is queen to a5 but if that
queen comes to a5 you're neglecting the defense
of this d6 pawn it's same deal with queen to c8
one of the ideas i have here is can i take take
and play knight to e4 coming after your bishop
coming after your pawn on d6 the bishop shore
could drop to e7 but know what you've done you've
neglected your king safety my queen come into
h6 or something like this could be what teddy is
eyeing in this position giving up his bishop for a
night but just trying to get after black's pieces
so as we get back to the live board we see teddy
over three minutes on the clock lars oscar down
to 222 lots of twos there and he is trying to say
i need to play faster because i'm down the clock
but i also need to deal with the fact that i'm
down upon here and he is ready at long last to
take this pawn on d5 his knight is no longer
pinned to the queen on d8 the queen has moved
out the way so this pawn can be captured and for
teddy it's now about figuring this out do i really
want to give up my bishop on f6 well with knight
e4 coming next i think that this is a good idea
but i can understand the hesitation why would i
want to give up my piece here this bishop could
be very powerful maybe it's best coming back at
some point to f4 this pawn on d6 is the target
if this knight moves out the way maybe i'll get a
bishop e7 if you're not careful do i want to play
bishop c4 just to defend this pawn right away
i'm not in love with that move bishop to c4 it
does make sense it also vacates the b5 square for
the knight to jump to to come after this d6 pawn
but i feel like bishop takes f6 that's where
i've set my mind on and right here teddy is
trying to figure it out himself so now he's down
under two minutes this is it can be a problem
when you're playing blitz chess you think that hey
it's a five minute time control i have all these
minutes here to use and now you're less time
than your opponent you're down 30 plus seconds
and you still haven't figured out a move in a
complex position so teddy looking at him here
he looks kind of just frozen he's really trying
to figure out the truth this position and lars is
moving non-stop twirling his hair he's trying to
figure this out i don't think he's happy about his
position but he should be happy about his clock
so teddy does in fact take on a six knight to e4
as i was calling for and this pawn on d6 is a
problem because if i can take that i would be
attacking your queen and your bishop this is why
lars brings his queen back to defend the bishop
and the pawn at the same time a very good move
by lars because he had just put his queen on c8
now he goes right back to d8 says hey let's
not worry you traded off your bishop and if you
continue taking once this queen takes here d6 is
not even under attack but it's protected for good
measure the queen is lined up on this diagonal
and very importantly this pawn on d5 is finally
falling down unless you bring your bishop back to
c4 so teddy goes in queen h6 i expect a very quick
bishop g7 i don't want this queen in here knight
g5 is a deadly threat so that's why the bishop
comes back and now knight takes d5 queen takes
d6 teddy's idea you take my d pawn i take yours
but this bishop on g7 it is super strong here the
pawn on b2 at the end of the diagonal will fall
in many of these lines so for teddy he's trying
to figure this out you know is that going to be
a problem for me for lars which pawn do i take do
i take on d5 and which piece do i take with maybe
i'll take with the bishop rather than the knight
the knight hits the queen but we know that if the
knight takes on d5 this pawn is still under threat
so perhaps the queen saves itself by stealing a
pawn in the process so right now lara's trying
to figure this out bishop takes d5 knight takes
d6 could be the play here and then bishop takes
b2 and it gets wild very fast i feel like black's
king is quite safe and this pawn is valuable but
white does have this outside pawn protected by the
bishop this kind of configuration here it's very
annoying as they protect one another they're just
stopping the rook's progress on the a file and
later in the game we can start thinking about
pushing this pawn but large goes for it he takes
the bishop one d5 now the b2 pawn can be captured
so i would try to take that he takes the knight on
f3 first i like that move because the queen needs
to stay in line with the knight on d6 the queen
would have preferred to take on f3 but you can't
do that with the knight hanging so lars seeing
the possibilities here we do have the presence of
opposite-colored bishops the bishop 1b5 remains
powerful on this diagonal it can also just go
right back to c4 going for the f7 pawn so despite
the fact that white's pawn structure on the king
side is worse you have compromised structure with
these double iso f bonds this f7 pawn on a light
square that could be the biggest issue on the king
side believe it or not and queen c7 lining up a
pin let's get a rook to d8 to bishop to f8 and go
after this pin piece and i think that's something
easy to miss you may think rook a to d8 is
coming because you're bringing your rooks towards
the center but in fact f28 would have allowed
bishop to f8 and this knight would have been in
trouble but now with queen of g3 that's a defended
square the knight is free to move say to e4 or c4
whoever it is safe after black attacks the p so
rook to d8 just knight to e4 and that's why lars
took this pawn on b2 teddy says okay defending
my knight on d6 my queen is free to go and i have
an open line and i will bring my next rook to the
second open line and that way i can try to take
control of the board so lars brings his a rook
to d8 keeping an eye on the f7 pawn but you know
what this pawn later in the game that rook is gone
so this pawn can start thinking about pushing not
yet the queen covers the square but teddy first
goes bishop c4 watch out for the capturing f7
lara says all right go for it it's two pieces for
a rook if you take on f7 that doesn't bother me
but teddy does go for it which surprises me here
because now if the rook takes f7 there's no way
to pile up on the pin piece if he get his rook out
quickly in attack that would be good but lars can
just biking g7 bishop takes f7 king takes back and
now it's two pieces for the rook and this a pawn
looks like it's in big trouble and probably just
being captured so if i'm teddy i'm thinking about
sacrificing an exchange right back maybe rook
h4 and take this bishop because with the knight
and he would be an extra pawn for white like if
you could play rook takes d4 now there's also this
nasty pin that's hard to get out of so teddy's
pushing his pawn instead hoping to trade off some
pieces but it looks like his king's in danger
i see the eval bar going in black's favor here
king e4 there's rookie three checkmates the king
had to drop back and look at this attacking pawns
and threatening forks 93 check it's a fork
it wins the game for black and i think teddy
will throw on the tower and he does so lars takes
game one he is up one game to none after one here
and largely just he's bopping he's feeling the
rhythm and his pieces we're doing the talking
there teddy he needs to strike back it was a fine
first game he got tactical he didn't handle some
of that tension center well at the key moments
but lars saw every idea that bishop takes f3
pinning the knight taking on b2 and teddy took on
f7 but it was his demise instead of black so here
we have game two underway black has the bishop
pair black has the better pawn structure you would
think because these are double pawns but white
plays in this manner because once you place a b3
look at the clamp and the position the d5 square
is under white's control and black considers
sometimes play c6 and d5 himself that way he
can fight for space because right now the pieces
aren't doing all that much and d5 is covered four
different ways by white's pieces so teddy on the
clock right now looking pretty calm lars and teddy
both trying to figure out the position here knight
to d7 i really really like this move the knight
can come to c5 with a tempo against the queen
but very importantly you're giving yourself the
option to play f5 black has a light square bishop
white does not so if i can play f5 and actually
give this bishop some open space to work with
that is clearly to block's benefit and f5 is not
weakening the king right now it would drop a pawn
so i'm not suggesting it at the moment but after
castling playing f5 makes a whole lot of sense
and here white can think about casting queen
side but one of the good things that teddy did
with bringing the knight to d7 is he's bringing
it towards the queen side right that can come
to c5 for example and after knight c5 you might
have to take because otherwise your c4 pawn is
not defended right knight c5 your queen moves back
well actually if you can't even go to d2 because
knight takes e4 and this pin is devastating
against uh white's queen here so after knight c5
you'd have to take and then i can just take back
with my bishop and say okay i have the bishop pair
against your knights but it is a closed position
so in closed positions the knights tend to reign
supreme and maybe you play f4 to open up the
king side something like that but the bishop pair
doesn't have the strength that you would prefer
to and that would require an open board state
so bishop takes knight takes c3 interesting choice
there by teddy i wonder if he felt like his bishop
was going to get in trouble if some kind of knight
d5 was the move and then the pawn would recapture
if it was taken and the bishop was stringed out
here but i don't really like voluntarily giving up
that bishop it's opposite color bishops now the
pawn on c4 is defended it's hard to attack that
some more maybe some kind of a6 b5 is a way
to just give up a pawn to open up the board
but teddy said plays b6 so he's playing against
the double pawn he's cementing that pawn in place
no c5 for you you're not getting this kind
of sacrifice or break and instead lars goes
g4 but where is the attack going to come from
you can start pushing all your pawns up and
then black plays g6 you'd have to play h4 h5
g5 g6 something like that but that also feels
too time intensive you're spending all these
moves pushing your pawns and i don't think
teddy is going to just sit and say what's lars
doing by pushing the pawns no he's trying to
attack and checking me not going to happen so
right now teddy has a choice to make here what
is he going for right now he's solid black has no
real weaknesses in the position but you want to
actually do something active here rather than
just sitting and waiting so he does knight to
c5 great that gets the piece active lars says no
i'm not going to touch that knight if i took on c5
the b-pawn takes thank you for the open b-file
no no no so queen to e2 he could take on c5 at
any moment the knight's not really going anywhere
and this bishop on e6 it does stare into the pawn
but what else queen c8 to a6 perhaps that's
an idea we see teddy go for it the queen on
a6 puts pressure on the c4 pawn also stares down
the eighth file that scores like a3 and a2 and i
said a3 first because if the queen comes to a6
you might play b3 but then you have to look at
the a3 squared not that it actually gets black
in attack or much of anything but that's where
i keep my eye on is these kind of squares on the
queen side so b3 is likely to be in white's future
but it's not necessary just at this moment and for
lars well what do i do h4 he's giving up this pawn
and that's an interesting choice he wants to
play f3 and open up the g file so if i'm teddy
i'll be very nervous before i capture this pawn
because bishop g4 pawn f3 and white's play next
comes very obvious like bishop e6 or let's say
bishop d7 something rook to g1 bishop h6 and
just this attack feels quite promising for white
especially in a blitz game so i don't think that
teddy wants to grab that pawn but he does
so he says the material is important to me
i don't mind if i do and i wonder if this bishop
can even come to h5 so you can play f5 next and
you defend actively by opening up lines for
your pieces and by playing f5 in the future
your rook can come to f7 to defend this pawn
your queen can go to d7 as well so teddy takes it
he plays bishop h5 he cannot drop his bishop to
g6 because of pawn h5 but i think he's going to
play pawn five here and as mentioned rook f7 queen
d7 and everything's defended but starts with king
h8 to not even allow bishop h6 to be played so i
understand this move it makes perfect sense to me
no bishop h6 my pawn can capture it it's no longer
pinned to a king on g8 so what do you do here for
lars how do you continue your attack do you play
queen to g2 then maybe rook to g8 and i just say
hey i'm just going to bottle up here you're not
making any progress remember that this queen it
would like to go in but this pawn f3 is also under
attack so the queen is doing an important job
defending this pawn f3 at this moment and if not
i think black does want to strike with f5 this
knight can come to e6 which simultaneously defends
the g7 pawn right that's a good defensive move
but knights are tricky because they also can just
hop forward as well from e6 into d4 f4 and if you
can trade off this bishop your king starts to feel
even safer so lars has quite a bit of extra time
here teddy has been deliberate in his approach
but he has taken upon so teddy is the material
lars has the potential attack and the extra time
but i like black's position because i don't quite
see the concrete attacking approach and that can
be very frustrating for a player look to g5 does
come to mind here as a way to attack this bishop
but i guess teddy is just gonna put his pawn on
g6 and it's another reason he put his king on
h8 just to stay out of the way so if there's a
sacrifice you take back your rook takes over the g
file first and there's no quick checkmate because
takes takes bishop h6 if this king were on g8 your
king is really in big danger but because the king
is in the corner you have the g8 square for your
rook to go to so king h8 was a nice profit log to
move anticipating what was going to happen and
that's why he teddy says i'm okay for now it's
reasonably safe and f5 is still a defensive move
that is aggressive you play moves like this to
clear the seventh rank as i was highlighting
earlier and it gives you quick chances to
play for an initiative against this pawn and f3 so
with 97 watch out knight f6 97 both of these are
moves after knight to d5 so you have to be careful
about that queen e6 drops this pawn in c7 so the
queen's doing an important task so make queen
d8 but then you have to think what if the bishop
replaces the rook on g5 that could be trouble for
the black queen and the dark square so teddy says
you want to get to f6 not so fast i am going to
put my pawn on the square protected by my rook and
doing something aggressive by attacking your rook
on g5 this is a great move f6 a very calm move
in the middle of a very intense position and
this bishop on h6 it attacks the rook takes
okay i'm gonna bring my rook up where's your
attack g7 got that covered maybe i'll play c6
but if you play c6 this queen can slide to g2
threading bishop g7 check ideas but this this
queen can come to g8 so c6 is probably a move
here it's risky i get it but this knight also
can come back to e6 i forgot about that knight
for now and teddy says i don't want to deal with
it your knight is not actually threatening me at
the moment c6 oh let's go back a sec c6 would have
blundered the f6 pawn because if you take there's
a check on g7 it's clear that this is not approved
maybe just queen to e6 or something like that and
there's a problem with the pieces here but knight
takes f6 was probably a concern and then having
an e6 does a good job of covering the g7 square
so black bringing the pieces back and now has more
time this is the problem with going for attacks
that you don't actually see the clear way forward
is you start burning your own clock and then you
have to justify the material sacrifice because
black is up a rook and a pawn for this bishop
and i get it the king is not perfectly safe in
the corner but you don't have anything as a clear
follow-up and now you're the one spending all
your time so teddy handles this very well he has
extra time and queen of g2 i think intentions are
pretty clear down the g file but guess what knight
rook cover g7 no check for you queen of rook cover
g8 so there's nothing there and that's why teddy
plays queen of d7 now his rook covers the last
rank his queen and brook cover the seventh rank
how are you going to checkmate this black king
so 93 perhaps there's a knight f5 i get it
but now that g7 is covered maybe knight f4 is
a reasonable move maybe knight d4 is a play and
the g7 square is very very important here and
it's just covered by too many of black's pieces
and the mod four so how can teddy rearrange his
pieces his rook would love to be on a square like
g6 or g8 sadly rooks are not queens they can't
move like that but that's what you want it's
trade off a rook and j plays rooks e8 going to
the e file there's not much happening there but
he's allowed knight to f5 and now this g7 square
one two three four and teddy says all right queen
to c8 he changed the order of his pieces this was
actually quite brilliant in fact by playing queen
d7 rookie 8 queen c8 he wants to put his rook on
g8 and that was his idea from the beginning but
his queen was in the way so he switches the order
of his heavy pieces trying to trade off on the g
file so queen h3 i think knight d4 is a good move
now just noting that this queen at the end of the
diagonal instead we see a trait on g8 you can take
with either piece bishop e3 threatening knight
h6 that's a four against your queen and your rook
this knight is now not very well defended queen to
g6 i'm already looking at ideas of knight takes d6
for example trying to get this knight as it lost
its defender now 20 seconds for black 12.7 for
what you got to move here you but you also don't
want your position to fall apart a couple moves
queen g6 is played knight takes pawn takes you get
the 96 but your king is feeling safer without this
knight on f5 so look at lars keeping the position
as close as locks as possible rook g8 there's
97 so teddy goes in with knight f4 he says this
knight is doing well queen g2 is a blunder because
the bishop takes f4 taking the knight which is the
defender of the queen and protecting the white's
queen at the same time so we see it capture it d6
is a problem he plays d5 but just take that thing
take it twice 97 probably a good move as well but
i think taking with the pawn was good that's a
past pawn now f5 teddy strikes with the diagonal
and oh knight f6 overlooked for sure f5 is falling
this is a problem queen e7 can be played but f4
defends and i think this is turning in lars's
favor very quickly so queen takes h5 rook takes
f6 is probably the move that gives black some hope
but right now black really cannot move the pieces
so queen g5 good move rook c6 watch out for the
c2 pawn that's the only place that can be attacked
but the queen needs to stay on g8 the rook
comes back first now queen c7 is a possibility
queen e6 blunders main one oh missed it queen
67 was made that's what happens when the knight
and queen lined up on h7 and overlooked by
lars and he kind of laughs i guess like how
could i miss that move now when the knight comes
back to d5 white is still doing well 1.4 seconds
and he wins a time he wins on time and neither
player can believe it are you kidding me are you
joking and lars is laughing he's like what just
happened and that's because lars missed checkmate
in one move and teddy was finding these tricky
resourceful ideas with no time on his own clock
and he actually wins the game because lars his
time elapses and that's that it's a 1-1 match
wow that was really an electric game there first
teddy was fending off the attack really well then
lars is still coming for him and yet teddy he
doesn't he doesn't see himself checkmated which
he allowed and unfortunately for lars he losing
the clock one one match at this point and we have
a dutch and this is called the raphael variation
so we're getting the ninja turtles here f3 i don't
know what this is but e4 saying let's just break
this board open and what's this pawn doing on a6
so in the dutch you play your pawn to f5 and
we kind of have almost a stone wall situation
but a6 that feels like a slow move and by playing
in this manner white is able to crack open the
center of the board here and your king is in the
center sure my king's in the center but i can go
this way and try to attack you later so this
is very weird i don't like the inclusion of a6
it seems that it's going to be promising for white
but teddy is thinking here probably wait this is
not what i was looking at in my preparation either
so i see the evaluation bar says plus 1.2 1.3
that's overestimating the position at least from
a human standpoint teddy's not sitting here and
thinking oh i have this humongous advantage i like
my position because instead of this palm being
on a6 maybe a move like knight c6 would have been
more useful for black but this is where we are and
e5 is tempting taking on d5 makes sense opening
the position even more this bishop can come to d3
have an open line to work with you can castle this
way we're going to castle in opposite directions
and this bishop does have more flexibility because
the pawn e6 is no longer there but there's so many
weakened squares vulnerable squares and these
light squares there may be a bishop here for
now but if this bishop gets traded white puts
a rook on the e file watch out you know look at
this control for the white side here so i like
teddy's position out of the gates and as we see
here a bishop trade is offered and black can say i
want to play queen d7 to defend but not so fast my
knight jumps in with tempo doesn't look very good
queen c8 would defend but then that queen's on
c8 so instead lars brings the knight into e4 but
if i take on e7 wait a sec let's go back a quick
moment here take on e7 queen takes e7 do i have
knight takes d5 knight takes d2 no because here
captures captures that's a check to your king
take back i'll take this one and then finally
your knight on e7 is under attack i was just
trying to take everything and see what happened
but black ends up a piece ahead so that would not
have been good so instead we saw a capture on e4
capture on e7 and there goes the knight to e5 and
we see a position here where black has a bishop
white has a knight white has the better pawn
structure and in fact saying take on e5 because
i will not recapture i don't have to recapture i
would take your bishop on f5 so that's why lars
castles and we can see a capture trait of knights
this pawn e4 is it a strength is it a weakness
it's an isolated pawn but it's a pass pawn and
isolated pawns are bad because they're harder to
defend you want to protect the pawn with another
pawn because when the more valuable pieces start
attacking it that way you don't have to deal and
teddy says oh speaking of deal look at my knights
in the center here hitting your queen queen d6
covers the c7 square the knight is still defended
knight back to e3 hopping around after this
bishop and where's that bishop going it goes to e6
the e4 pawn does not feel quite as safe so i
would probably take on d7 and maybe consider
d5 myself why not try to push and go after this
pawn take over space bring a rook to d1 hey
that's a pass pawn for myself just like your e4
pawn is passed but a knight is a great blockader
so we'll see if this kind of thing happens lars is
on the clock here trying to figure out well where
does my bishop go can i leave it there for now
he plays knight takes e5 leaving it the knight
can capture on f5 which hits the queen but the
queen can move somewhere to attack this knight
right back and remember this pawn on d4 is pinned
so the knight on e5 is not actually capturable
so teddy sitting and thinking he has a choice
of two which piece are we going to take on f5
with because you cannot take on e5 you drop
your queen on d2 that would be a big blunder
so which piece are we going to use to take this
bishop if knight takes f5 knight f3 check would
be a good idea if not for rook takes f3 and the
reason why i say knight f3 check it blocks the
rook's defense of this knight but after pawn
takes rook takes maybe this is okay for white
if i steal your next pawn but i don't like this
open king that worries me for sure so i would not
want to take with the palm but you can take with
the rook on f3 but teddy says up let me take with
the rook my knight can follow suit my next rook
can come on f1 and i'm trying to remove some of
the important pieces around your king so your
rook on f8 is more valuable in this position
knight c4 knight g4 would be good tactics if the
f8 rook we're not hanging with check the reason
why it will knight c4 they can just take with
the knight so let's go knight g4 i'm threatening
to checkmate you here if you take rook takes a
five that's not good of course but the problem is
i take on f8 with check and then i take your
knights that distraction tactic will not work out
and that's why laura's sitting and thinking well
where does my knight go should i leave it here and
take this first but then the knight hops in this
rook follows this queen come to g5 that doesn't
look so fun that looks kind of scary for my king
and my pawn structure is worse that's an isolated
pawn whereas white has all the pawns in a row here
everything is nicely compact and queen d7 hitting
the knight keeping this pawn on d4 pinned so what
next queen at g5 rook to f1 both these moves do
make sense to me if rook f1 maybe we'll see rook
to f8 just following the rook along the f line
knight f3 check is still a possibility after
rook to f4 let's not forget about that tactic
where i can block your defense of the knight by
sacrificing my own knight so queen g5 does make
sense but then you're leaving this pawn on d4
that will feel a little bit vulnerable though
the knight has to move out the way first that
will give you a tempo to play more like c3 next
so queen f4 similar idea as queen to g5 and now
the knight really is under attack this pawn e4
is under attack and that's just the simpler move
sometimes we get in our heads we need to be super
aggressive we put our queen to g5 but queen f4
says i'm going to win your pawn e4 keep talking
about that that's a weakness it's isolated let
me go after it it's not defended and now two
pieces in the center are under attack and this
pawn on e4 is falling so we'll see here what can
lars do he is down nearly 20 seconds at this point
he can make a move like knight to c6 which saves
the knight but it does not save his pawn on e4 and
by the way we should watch out for a queen g4 move
because when we get pieces in line with each
other we could think about what happens when the
piece gets out of the way but of course let's take
this pawn e4 first the major downside is the rook
coming to e8 taking over an open file attacking
the queen but that's why i'm saying queen g4 is
a possibility because if these queens get in line
with one another and there could be a discovery
with a knight hopping out the way and the players
they're feeling the pressure right now i see them
there teddy trying to figure this out hand on face
lars sitting back but his eyes that's all you need
to know is look at those eyes he is really just
trying to figure out i'm down a pawn here but i
should have compensation i have an open file
this d4 pawn needs to have an eye kept on it
so black's pieces are doing quite well you
have a rook that's developed and here we go
what was i telling you lining this up watch out
for knight h6 check so the king might have to come
to h8 but that costs you a move and then white can
play a move like c3 perhaps and defend this pawn
on d4 d5 is possible the queen will not be able
to capture it because the g7 pawn is hanging with
checkmate but that's why king h8 was played just
getting out of the way of this discovery knight h6
can still be played because the queen is protected
but that's not a movie you want to play unless it
comes with force so knight to h6 not what you
want so g6 then maybe the knight comes to h6 or
to e3 to defend the queen the point being that
you cannot take my knight because your queen
is under attack so we have a stare down with
queens my knight comes and defends but actually
in this kind of situation you may just get
your rook into e2 and that gives black some
real compensation along the second rank here that
active rook is nice so we'll see how lars responds
here he is down upon so even if he trades queens
gets that rook down to e2 it may look good but
are you getting your material back is it enough
is this rook going to come to f1 and actually do
the same thing and that would be worse because
the black king is on that side of the board
and there are plenty of checkmating nets that
you could fall into for example g6 let's say we
get this position with a queen trade rook e2 and
you say okay i'm just going to go ahead and take
your pawns then my rook gets to f7 my next move
is knight f6 and i'm going to go checkmate you
on the h7 square so that's a mating net with the
king being on h8 and you may start taking pawns
good for you well it's checkmate because my knight
covers the last square this is not going to happen
but these things can happen especially as we get
into the bullet portion of these bliss games right
right now right now white has a minute and 10
seconds black has 27 seconds so lars is down on
the clock you make a quick move that you regret
and you could actually find yourself checking it
so teddy makes a very good decision just brings
his knife back instead of bringing the rook to f1
that was more tactical in nature felt unnecessary
you kind of want to keep the rooks on the board
uh so queen e7 watch out your knights under attack
rookie one you're walking into a pin but you also
know your knight can come to c2 which defends
the e1 square so queen g3 played rookie one
now makes sense from f1 if you want
to trade the rooks i'm not sure you
really want to try the works that badly but teddy
says don't mind if i do it makes me feel safer
i don't have to worry about my king i am up a pawn
so if i can trade rooks and i trade queens that's
the ideal situation so we see the rook trade
step one now let's see if we get the queen trade
knight g3 knight f5 that's a good looking idea and
that e3 can come in d5 or f5 knight f5 actually
threatens to win this pawn that's why the king
moved up to h7 but queen if check okay teddy a
chance to trade queens or check and take on b7
that king on h7 is in a bad spot but so teddy's
taking up space now knight d5 goes after this pawn
here c6 your pawn structure is cemented over there
on the queen side that leaves the b7 pawn as a
potential target so knight e6 played defending
not committing to a pawn structure choice now
play c6 this knight should come back to e3 i
believe and then try to go back over to f5 you
have this d6 square that could be annoying as well
so no forks but 92 check could be dangerous for
this king i like knight f5 as a possibility here
knight d3 is an option but the queen would just
move knight g6 played queen needs to stay in line
with the knight queen d8 check i feel like if
you go knight d6 queen f4 happens and you may
win the b7 pawn which is actually not easy to win
because you walked into a pin but you're getting
your queen away from the safety of this king and
this king could be susceptible to some kind of
perpetual check so here comes knight f4 watch out
for the king 11 seconds teddy is the one in more
time trouble all of a sudden and he goes king h2
that way he can push his g pawn and tiger king
that looks weird to me 97 check 97 looked good
you could have forced the queens off queen five
he takes this pawn he has no fear he's i don't
need to trade queens queen d7 back and then queen
f5 that's his idea of h4 which looks scary queen
f5 check trading the queens you want a second
pawn you win the game so queenie a check nice find
there this punk queen h8 you can go back and forth
he said goes queen e4 h4 that was knight f5 that's
why g6 was played protecting both squares queen
comes back to e3 now the pawn is pushing here goes
that pawn all right knight to d6 is possible just
don't blunder checkmate here's a queen here knight
g4 that's a really good defensive place queen e5
check if you want it trade take with the pawn you
are up two pawns b5 is tempting but i wouldn't go
there just yet but b5 would spring free this
outside pass pawn king e3 is a blunder knight
c2 checks oh he lost in time wow oh my gosh and
look at lars he's just like uh karma my friend
you know we're in a pretty even matchup right now
but i know what happened in game two game three
it's your time to lose so wow wow wow i cannot
believe that that just happened here oh my gosh
what a match we've had it's two to one lars oscar
howard in the lead teddy coleman up two pawns in
that final position i don't even know what to make
of this so i will take the time during this break
to get my head back in order both players really
playing some exciting chess we'll be right back
after this short break is i'm not gm speechless
championship match brought to you by chess.com
and in this matchup between i am teddy coleman
and i am lars oscar hogg it is a 2-1 lead
for lars the norwegian player he is jumped ahead
of teddy he won game one teddy struck back in game
two and lars wins game three on the clock down
two pawns in the position but fair is fair teddy
did win game two on time when he was in a losing
position so it evens out right now lars is the
lead but both players should be feeling pretty
confident they've done a good job they've gotten
the positions they've wanted and particularly
in this game three with the white pieces teddy
should be happy with how the game went so it's
a close one it's anybody's match at this point
and they are playing in this quarterfinals
match here there's 300 to the winner the
three next three hundred dollars is split by win
percentage so every game counts every point counts
and these players they just want to move on they
want to win this tournament that's their focus
and both of them they have their chances so the
games are about to get back and here we go we have
game four underway and we have f4 on move one by
lars so he goes for the birds opening and this is
seen as somewhat risky from white's point of view
because any time you push this golden pawn that's
upon f2 the pawn f7 your king can get in more
danger you open up a diagonal against your king
so that can be a problem as the game continues and
look knight f6 very simple development by black if
knight g4 comes at the right moment you're already
eyeing scores like e3 and f2 so white is the one
who needs to be a bit careful he plays e3 and he's
kind of a player of my own heart kind of said i
play in online blitz and now watch out with the
bishop of knight here if e4 e5 comes that will win
a piece so e4 is not defended right now and this
bishop can just drop back to h7 preemptively so
i know what you're up to but watch out for a
timely e4 move that would be problematic for
black but for now too many pieces are covering
the square so it's not actually a direct threat
so black and played move like c5 knight to d7 just
developing all these pieces all your miners are
now you got to move e4 is coming and that would
be devastating to see because i attack your bishop
and then i play e5 so you should either move your
bishop say to b4 that way if e4 is not impossible
because your knight is pinned but even if it were
possible e5 doesn't win a piece and alternatively
you can drop your bishop back to h7 or to g4
to make sure e4 doesn't even come with tempo
so teddy does the bishop h7 he has just over four
minutes lars over four and a half minutes for
himself so the opening battle i would say has been
won by white even though black's position is solid
there's no weaknesses it's about the time and i
like the fact that lars is up by half a minute
and teddy can think at some point about playing
e5 that's a reasonable choice but with the king
still in the center i probably wouldn't commit to
that just yet queen e7 speaks to me that way you
retain some flexibility where's my king wanna go
does it want to go king side can i go queenside
if you go side you may be walking into an attack
because you don't have that many defenders over
there but at the same time maybe you can launch
an attack against this king on g1 when there's
pawn f4 that looks good because it takes up
space but also it's easier to crack with a g5
so that's why i'm thinking perhaps teddy wants
the castle long and get his king away from
white's king and lars he strikes too quickly
for that even to be considered so teddy does
play e5 that way white can't do the same and
now i'm not really threatening to take on f4
i'm just going to leave my pawn in place if i'm
thinking about this from teddy's perspective
this pawn stops a lot of white's activity
and this bishop on c1 is behind the pawn
if you commit to f5 that's a really risky choice
while it makes the bishop on h7 look pretty bad
there's no more pawn tension and your pawn e4
isn't exactly the soundest pawn there is and
black would try to get at that pawn and castle
very likely to the queen side so remains to be
seen how large reacts he does play f5 so i like
it from a for the point of view that it makes
this bishop look bad at some point there could be
h3 g4 g5 especially if this king comes this way
which is why i think the king should end up going
to the queen side but it's not risk-free there
this bishop comes to e3 puts pressure on the a7
pawn for example these pawns can start pushing
up the board so i do prefer white's position i
think that lars should be confident he should
be enjoying the current dynamic but as the game
continues this bishop on g2 isn't exactly the
best piece and it's going to need to defend this
pawn on e4 that's what black would like to attack
so let's see what can black do now a4 this says
hey you don't want to castle this way and a5 says
you're right i probably don't want to castle
queenside you still can oddly enough because while
you've pushed upon in front of your king it's hard
to attack and by playing a5 b4 is not going to
happen so teddy plants his knight in c5 this pawn
is under attack i would have considered putting
the bishop on b4 first and then attacking this
knight on c3 but okay knight c5 it does make sense
putting pressure on the e4 pawn bishop e3 drops
the pawn directly this queen is doing an important
job defending the pawn so white needs to figure
out how to continue in 92 it makes sense opening
up all the pieces to defend this pawn so this
whole game is centered around well the center this
e4 pawn and black would like to play g6 but you'll
notice that knight f6 would have lost its defender
which is why teddy brought his knight back to
d7 first and g6 can be played in the near future
trying to open up this bishop on the diagonal so
lars has developed very normally all the pieces
have a function here black's pieces not quite as
much a bishop g5 could be played to try to offer
an exchange of those bishops but this bishop can
even drop right back to g1 and say my bishop is
better than yours i don't want to trade and of
course rook to d1 trying to get this d6 square
is possible if this bishop were ever to leave
the e7 square so i do likewise position seems
easier to play both players concentrated right
now bishop g8 wow f6 let my bishop play in this
game too okay that's actually pretty reasonable
because if you play f6 and say bishop f7 then you
can castle more safely so bishop f3 says if you
play f6 guess what i'm going to give you a check
on the diagonal that's pretty clever play by lars
responding to teddy's move with a bishop move zone
and well what now f6 check bishop f7 takes takes
this doesn't look very friendly for the king
it's never going to find true shelter so that's
why lars put his bishop on f3 and just to show
you the difference is let's say had he played rook
to d1 f6 yeah you get your one check but bishop f7
blocks it and that's a queen that's a bishop the
bishop wins that battle so that's why lars played
bishop to f3 teddy here sitting and thinking
trying to figure out all right what what next
how do i do this do i try to push g6 like is that
actually a reasonable try to free this bishop up
or is that going to open the position and the king
is in the center can i castle to the queen side
my king can't castle king said there's a bishop
in the way and if i cast a queen side am i somehow
going to walk into a mating attack and the most
important thing right now is look at teddy time
he's a minute and nine seconds and a tough
position so he does in fact allow the trade
of bishops if i'm large i'm trading there and i'm
going after this king and that might involve a g4
an h4 g5 something like that but teddy's gonna
say you can't check with me that quickly i do have
some time maybe that includes a queen d8 queen
eight to trade the queens rook d8 was played
instead let's try to trade some brooks but this
rook you're playing a rook down in the position
because the rook is stuck behind the king and the
king can't get out because the queen's on h5 and
what king g8 king h7 no i'll put my queen on g6
and check you off so your king can't even move out
the way so here comes rook to d1 this position
no fun for black none whatsoever and what next
if you gain black okay of course black is starting
to win a piece but if this piece we're not hanging
what is black's actual plan here to get the
pieces out and on the flip side white needs
to make use of this open line that's essential
here maybe bishop takes c5 is a move and after
takes you take this knight on b6 i'm trying to get
my rook somewhere along this defile if i work gets
in the game black is in some huge huge trouble i'm
just not quite seeing the knockout blow right now
so lars he's sitting and thinking he does have
over two minutes to teddy's 56 seconds but we've
seen the clock dwindle we somehow seen players who
have had way more time spent too much of it and
then they're the ones who are scrambling to make
the final moves of the game so right here lars
takes that pawn on a5 okay this knight moves out
the way this is under attack so knight takes a4
seems pretty reasonable at this point and this e4
pawn isn't that well defended talked about this a
long time ago but if this knight on c3 can be
removed then this pawn on e4 becomes a target
later in the game so i move like knight c4 i can
just take this knight and then take this pawn
and steal your essential pawn but this dynamic
here is the most problematic the black king can't
get out so you need to somehow get this rook if
you could play rook jumps over king to d8 your
position is perfectly acceptable but with your
rook stuck on h8 you're not a happy camper so
knight takes on a4 this part of b2 is under attack
knight c4 there is b5 that is available to black
and this b2 pawn might be lost and where is this
knight actually going so suddenly this is turning
around and teddy has 35 seconds lars has a minute
25 still more time for white but teddy's moves
are becoming a bit easier so if he can play them
quickly then he can try to bounce back here and i
see that that move was not approved of and knight
d2 was played and i don't think that's going to
uh do the trip i think like rook a1 actually
trying to get the open a file would have been
useful for white but instead knight to d2 so can
you just take this pawn because the rook if it
goes to a1 i just go knight a4 back and i close
down the a file so queen c8 play instead queen e8
is probably the plan and i want to play king
f7 really really badly so if i play queen eight
and your queen moves back somewhere and then i can
move my king up that's the goal so look at this
you see the eval bar it's going down king f7 or
king g8 king hw you do have some time knight h4
knight g6 does look scary but teddy's gonna go
king to h7 and rook g8 as the knight comes in
look at this rookie g8 he has 11 seconds left so
he is down on time but his position is getting
better this pawn is under attack if you push
it in comes his knight to c3 which attacks the
rook attacks the pawn i guess that might need
to be a bit careful here as it looks promising
just if you could take on h6 and follow with
queen takes hx it would be checkmate but your
rook would somehow need to be on the h
file to do the trick and that's far away
so how is lars going to take over here knight
c3 i'm jumping in thank you don't mind if i do
give me this pawn and you have to give me this
pawn you can play rook e1 and that defends the
pawn tactically or so it would seem but if the
rookie one takes bishop h6 haha knight f2 that
is a fork i don't have to recapture your bishop
instead i check you and i win your queen in this
manner so that is something to keep an eye on uh
that black has available rook a1 rook a7 okay i
see this that looks threatening but if you move
the bishop queen h6 is checkmate he loses on time
teddy just loses some time he couldn't find a
move and he loses on time here and i get it just
bring up i'm gonna bring up that end position
very quickly just to show you the final tactic
that queen takes h6 check was the threat if
you move this bishop anywhere let's say to
c5 queen takes h6 is checkmate because
the king is on h7 the g7 pawn is pinned
and that's why teddy he couldn't find a move and
he just loses on the clock because look at this
your bishop's under attack you know queen takes
h6 is coming what are you to do here it's just
that kind of position probably queen d8 to get
into d1 that was necessary to counter against
this king but really difficult to find with
just a few seconds in the clock so i understand
how teddy saw that game it's like this one's gone
and really that game was about time management but
also lars gave him credit he kept preventing teddy
from finishing his development that rook on h8
it made one move it went to g8 eventually at long
last but he didn't have enough time to figure out
the rest of the game so credit to lars he played
a nice game there and teddy with the white pieces
now we have a more standard setup it's a nimble
indian the bishop comes to b4 to pin this knight
maybe you'll take it at some moment and the pawn
will have to capture but you have double pawns
there but teddy has not wasted a move playing a3
so if a3 then black is more inclined to take the
knight because white spent this turn playing
a3 which doesn't help the rest of the board
bishop d2 says okay you can take on c3 i'll take
with my bishop but he also could have castled
and he may not have spent time playing a3 but
lars says i'm going to get your bishop taste is
that's fine with me i'll take it right back with
my rook and look at my bishop on d3 staring at
your king my knight is developed so i'm perfectly
happy with this position so it's just you know
a standard a strategic battle i should say where
white has the bishop hair and you can try to keep
the bishop pair with bishop e1 but look at the
stronghold over the e4 square by black's pieces
and you have to watch out because this queen
can venture in this rook can also lift its way
up to the sixth rank and then this attack could
be dangerous for the white king but strategically
now i keep talking about this as a strategic uh
versus a tactical battle in a way that this is
also kind of risky because if white is able to
break through on the queen side you may not have
enough time to attack the white king because white
is infiltrating on the queen side so a5 played if
takes i think that lars will throw in knight takes
c3 and that way the rook can recapture on a5 i
don't want to take back with the pawn because then
white has access to the c5 square and so if this
capture knight takes c3 removes the guard or the
a5 square and then the rook can capture so lars
actually voluntarily takes on c3 brings his knight
to d7 guess what then i can come to f6 and then
you know where maybe the e4 you can also
play for e5 as you have that square defended
so teddy needs to figure out all right what's
the best way to react right now do i put my
queen on b3 do i this e6 pawn and maybe not
don't put my queen on c2 to stop e5 because
the f5 pawn is saying well then i lose sight of
my knight on f3 right bishop takes f3 as possible
so even individual moves at this point are not
so easy for white i think black's position is
much more simple your plan you brought your
knight out okay maybe i'll go negative six
maybe i'll go queen of six maybe go rook f6 maybe
i'll go e5 i see all of these options for black
whereas white's moves for the most part tend to
have some kind of drawback and queen e2 was played
this knight can simply hop in to f6 and then
maybe to e4 this pawn as mentioned go e5 but i
believe teddy's idea is to take and then push
his pawn to e4 so no e5 e4 for you just like
in the last game when today was black he saw that
epon mobilizing he said i can also push my own so
we have this set up knight f6 good move by lars
trying to bring this knight into e4 i would not
be surprised if teddy drops his knight back to d2
to deal with that idea and e5 even if it weren't
attacked twice is not possible just yet because
the f5 pawn is hanging and needs the e6 pawn's
defense which means perhaps d5 is a good move
right i just talked myself in this i thought e5
isn't available to black because it's f5 pawn but
d5 is possible because of this very same f5 pawn
and teddy moves the rook back to c2 first that way
94 did not come with a tempo and laura says okay
queen e7 teddy says don't mind if i do let's break
open the queen side and now he has two pawns and
the rook defending the square this rook can double
on the c file if black does capture and well white
looks like first of the punch c6 is not out of
the question either it closes down the queen side
in large part but it pushes the bishop back and
takes over some space so c6 i wouldn't that's
not my first instinct i don't want to play that
move but it's something you should consider and if
you're lars you may consider putting your bishop
on one of these two squares just to get outside
of the pawn if c6 is indeed the plan so bishop e4
to trade bishops try to get this knight in here
bishop d5 says you can't kick my bishop off this
great d5 square so i don't mind if i sit on it so
let's see lars down 10 seconds he takes a takes b
oh you don't you can actually decide to take this
first if you want to open the c file you could
take on b6 and then take this back because by
taking on b6 you're attacking the c7 pawn so teddy
has a choice but he shouldn't spend too much time
making his move here that's been a fatal flaw
of his we've seen him in pretty decent positions
and then he has 10 seconds left so right now is
not the time to sit and think for a minute maybe
think for half a minute because it does change the
trajectory of this game but you cannot burn all of
your time on this one move and he's still thinking
two minutes and 15 seconds of counting down lars
now has a pretty significant lead on the clock
and i do like white's position i don't see a huge
problem with it but i'm going to see a problem
with it if he keeps thinking and i guess you
could actually throw the move c6 as well pushing
the bishop back and then taking on b4 so he does
have a lot to consider i get it i'm fully on board
with it but we've seen what happens to him when he
spends all his time and that's why i'm advocating
against it so he's still thinking here still
hasn't made a move just make one you got to make a
good move quickly rather than the best move slowly
so what i'm trying to figure out what he's even
considering and what he's actually going to do
here he takes on b6 and if i'm lars i would
even just take back right away i don't want
to calculate is this rook takes c7 happening
i see the bishop can take on f3 but lars spent
essentially 10 seconds to tell
you a minute and 15 seconds
and that's the biggest difference right now this
knight gets the d5 score it is a monstrous piece
here it stops any kind of rook c7 ideas it puts
pressure on the d4 pawn this pawn can go to b5
but you want to double in the c file and then it's
like well so what you double the c file no no no
you're not getting in and this knight on d5 is
helping so maybe white will play e4 rook on c1
e4 type of stuff that way you can challenge this
knight and trade it off but that's very committal
as well because your d4 pawn becomes weaker and
all that stuff so rook to b1 play protecting the
b4 pawn make sure that your queen is free to
move but move to where what's the plan maybe
bishop c4 to take this knight i don't really
like leaving this diagonal because i just have
this in the back of my mind if the black bishop
gets the e4 that can be a problem and actually
e4 would be a big blunder because it moves like
rook takes d3 and knight f4 and this e4 pawn is
a problem it's hanging so do not play e4 here i do
not recommend that and what else can i recommend
this queen is doing an important duty of defending
this uh bishop also the c3 square the knight would
like to jump in you know queen e2 knight c3
thank you for material so white's position
remains harder to play maybe bishop b5 and bishop
c6 that way at least i'm infiltrating on one of
the c file squares and maybe two of them because
the c8 square is also defended by the bishop
and my bishop on d3 isn't doing all that much so
actually bishop b5 to c6 looks very reasonable
just trying to get this bishop off and rook a8
says okay i'm gonna take over the a-file still
i'm looking at this idea for white like let me get
my bishop in and h3 okay deliberate let's see what
black can do so i was looking at it from white's
perspective now i'm gonna flip over to black's
perspective how do i improve here if my knight
goes to f6 is it coming to e4 perhaps but i'm
giving up the c7 square so queen e8 was the choice
queen can come to a4 queen come to h5 i like the
flexibility of this move and it also stops the
idea i was talking about bishop b5 to c6 so teddy
goes bishop c4 but he doesn't want to take this
the bishop lands on d5 and that's not exactly
promising for white's position so knight e1 that
way i don't blunder my knight on the square the g
pawn is pinned so knight takes something like
knight takes e3 is a big threat here so 91 is
played this knight could also try to go to the f4
square eventually probably not yet bishop f1 can
be played just to defend this g2 pawn and if this
knight were here then you could take on d5 and put
your knight in f4 so it would tactically be okay
look at teddy rook a2 good move 34 seconds left
lars now under min on the clock a rook trade
is offered and with one pair of rooks off white
feels less cramped white did have less space so by
trading off the rooks there is more space for your
remaining pieces f4 watch out for a shot like that
because this rook on b1 is in line with the queen
but the bishop is defending that's square for
now so f4 probably doesn't work out rook c1 well
open file let's take it now i can consider
taking on d5 to get my rook to c7 doesn't
quite do the trick just yet so i wouldn't
take on d5 until it's necessary so knight d3
is not even possible because if you take an e3
i take back with my pawn and g2 is protected
if knight d3 knight takes b4 i guess that's one of
the problems knight f4 hits the queen though and
does both so interesting moment here maybe there's
rook takes a2 though that's probably the biggest
issue is there's like all these tactics that play
here knight c3 at some point but rook takes a2
should do the trick because you take here take
and this is under attack this is under attack here
takes takes and thank you for your rook at the end
so that's the problem with moving your knight from
e1 is the tactics will favor black so bishop
c4 knight f6 bishop d3 knight e4 okay pieces
are moving trades are being offered finally that
knight is out of there but when you play f3 look
at the e3 square and when you look at e3 look at
d4 a pawn chain is only as strong as the base of
the pawn chain this is the base now before it was
on f2 and everything was safe now it's an e3 which
doesn't feel quite as good but look at teddy
brings the knight in and he's in a five seconds
he's got to move queen c3 off from the queen trade
he thinks that he's getting safer by doing this
we have a trade knight back to c3 b5 knight a4
watch out because this pawn could be a target but
that's why the nitrate is offered and i believe
that this position is quite level but with teddy's
clock being a 5.7 seconds left that's how things
can go wrong even if you have an objectively drawn
position you can blunder into things but look all
the pawns are in dark squares so this bishop is
strong but it can't attack anything and the king
can't get in there's no access points for the king
so i would just you can even leave the pawns
and put your bishop to c4 no king e6 for you
and yeah he's gonna shuffle back and forth and
there's no threat like you could take out f4 i
just take back these pawns are all defending so it
takes 2.8 seconds though you got to move 3.1 not
showing the steadiest bullet hand throughout this
match this far bishop e2 he could play or he's
going to trade everything and play bishop
e2 now but f4 the king starts getting in
you have to be a little bit careful here
bishop d3 but he made 0.3 seconds left
he lost some time again he can't control it
right now it's slipping away because he has
no time remaining and teddy in those moments
he's spending too much time early and he's not
showing the confidence when he gets into just
under 10 seconds remaining he's the one who's
nervous and he can't make the move in time and
that's why lars has this four to one lead even
though that position was objectively equal or you
saw the zeros in the eval bar didn't have time to
reach the conclusion that he wanted so now here's
the black pieces lars goes for a more standard
opening instead of the birds opening with one f4
we see that we're in pretty much a normal position
bishop on f4 reminiscent of the london system but
the pawns on c4 so it's kind of like a hybrid like
instead of just in london with a closed dynamic
it's an open london and castle's king side makes
sense white is going to try to castle kingside
soon as well bishop e2 first and castle and black
can play for c5 this is a standard way to chop
at white center as you push the pawn to c5 you
say i'm going to trade some pieces off my knight
wants to go to c6 but it doesn't attack anything
without the pawn putting pressure on the center
so i like the move c5 here teddy is considering
his options he plays knight to d5 which i also
like if you take and i take with the pawn well
how are you going to win back this pawn on c4 not
seeing it and otherwise i'm threatening to take on
c3 and win a pawn in this manner so knight takes
pawn takes bishop takes where's this rook going
where is this rook on here here rook c1 bishop
b2 this rook has nowhere to go and yet the
computer still likes white maybe there's some kind
of queen b3 queen takes b7 like rook b1 something
like this where you end up getting the b7 pawn
and the c7 pawns also under attack so it's funny
how you can kind of blunder and it still works
out well for you sometimes these things happen
and chest is strange like that and knight
g5 also is an idea in such a position so
bishop took and went back to a5 this is smarter
and it's the second time where teddy with the
black pieces has stolen a pawn in the earlier game
he took this g4 pawn and he was doing a good job
of fending off the attack here there won't be an
attack but it's going to be a positional grind
where black's pieces don't exactly have that much
space and this pawn c7 needs to have an eye kept
on it but this bishop can just sit on b6 which
defends the b-pawn along the file and it protects
c7 directly so this knight can now develop i
prefer the black's position in a blitz game
i see that the evaluation bar says white has a
slight edge it's because the center looks good
you're fully developed with your minor pieces
and your rooks out that that's all good that
all looks great but how do you actually say i'm
in this for the long run you are down a pawn and
you start feeling that as the game continues like
wait am i going to get my material back is there
a way for me to maybe lose some of my activity
but gain material back and i see that queen e2
was played and the eval bar dropped a little
bit and that's how tricky these positions are
i don't know the perfectly precise move in
that position but clearly queenie two was
not the number one best move and it makes perfect
sense you're playing e4 to get this bishop
and to push your pawns in the center bring this
rook to d1 where your rook's in line with his
queen so i get what white's doing and yet it's
saying oh black is doing really well and it's
because black has an extra pawn so h3 no bishop
g4 for you if i played e4 too soon maybe you'd
play here and then my d4 pawn is weak so instead
h3 is played this knight can go to f6 but that
gives the e5 square it's the knight so it's a
four jump for both and teddy does go knight f6
he's saying my extra pawn speaks volumes here
maybe he'll play c6 maybe he'll play bishop
c7 the bishop on a5 isn't exactly doing that
much it's taking away the e1 square from a rook
but there doesn't really need to or want to go
to the e1 score anyway so i think that c6 would
be a reasonable play especially if you can get
bishop c7 to follow and maybe knight d5 move
is coming as well because if i get knight to d5
i'm attacking this maybe i have some knight c3
ideas so lars plays bishop h2 i like that move if
you want to play knight d5 go ahead now i have e4
with the fork my bishop on f4 is no longer
under attack so i like this move bishop h2
it's just saying i'm gonna play safely but
now knight e4 is reasonable bishop e4 is also
reasonable and c6 as i mentioned it's played you
can play b5 not now because the c6 spawns under
attack but if you wanted to be aggressive b5 was
available the knights on e5 f3 maybe e4 to come
maybe g4 hitting this bishop so black still
lacks a bit of like play for the pieces
your pieces are about to get attacked and white's
pieces are perfectly safe in this position
knight d5 is e4 okay not great bishop c7 that
looks good knight d7 perhaps is next where i
can trade off this knight on e5 and training
pieces should help the side with extra material
and in this case it's black with an extra
pawn so 97 looks plenty reasonable to me
and there's played so e4 is a possibility
the bishop can go sit back on g6 and maybe
the knight will take it but we're starting
to trade pieces this bishop 182 i can capture
with check and now we're getting into an easier
simplification where black remains upon ahead
so bishop g6 f4 wow f5 one of the ideas there's a
bishop on c4 very powerful this 95 wants to stay
here and teddy needs to figure out can he take on
e5 with this knight and perhaps d takes e5 it may
look worrisome but it would look even worse if
this rook could come back to f1 but something
like takes takes and g4 and f5 that doesn't look
very fun who wants to see themselves get attacked
in this manner it may not work out perfectly for
white maybe there's like a queen h4 at some point
and a bishop b6 check and maybe there's problems
in white's position as well but it feels pleasant
for white at first glance with a rook on the open
file so teddy does take he plays bishop b6 and
well queen h4 different move order same position
that i was calling for but i see the eval bar it's
in white's favor i don't know if i would agree
with that from a practical point of view bishop h5
is kind of a threat because g4 loses the sight of
this pawn on h3 and he plays g4 voluntarily so he
gives up this pawn to play f5 and trap the bishop
okay wow now there is a lot to figure out here
can i hmm what can you do here so queen
h3 f5 bishop is trapped but can i take
a bunch of times in f5 or is the king on g8
actually somehow worse than the king on h1
it's weird when you're pushing your pawns the
king on h1 looks like there's a lot of air in
front of it that could be dangerous but it's this
king on g8 that could see itself in harm's way
i would somehow take and after f5 i would allow
this capture but i wouldn't take here i don't
want this bishop to look strong so i'd make
him like rook to d8 and after it takes take
i say well is your bishop that strong you have a
bishop for what three pawns here and your bishop
isn't that powerful so something like this could
be teddy's best bet and instead he says no no i
want my bishop i'm going to play h5 and i
see that eval bar it approves it's saying
that black is just hanging right in this
thing but because white is down material
one pawn in fact and still the eval bar says it's
pretty decent that would scare me and just by the
looks of this right aesthetically white's position
looks powerful look at all these pawns here
marching forward and bishop h7 maybe that's the
move i know you're giving up a pawn on e6 but
the bishop will be free and teddy decides to keep
the material but that's not the way to go i don't
i don't feel and i would have taken the jeep 100 i
would have taken this way and brought my rook to g
there's a bishop here so i can't go with g1 just
yet but i wanted to go rook to g1 but that's uh
taking towards the center instead of away
from it and we get to this position where e6
very tempting and the point of e6 is if you take
and i take with my pawn i'm throwing e7 with
check against your king but takes with the bishop
now this i don't like from lars's point of view i
think that the position is opening up and somehow
black's king is getting safer unless there's some
kind of timely bishop e5 and a checkmate here
but that's why teddy when rook d8 he's trying
to trade off this attacking piece give me the d
file and this pawn h3 is still hanging by the way
you shouldn't forget about that and i want
to get my bishop to d4 where it defends this
pawn on g7 so i will give you my b7 pawn have
fun with this irrelevant queenside pawn it may
restore material quality but it's not going
to be sufficient so i think the next rook can
and maybe should come over to d8 as well and
said taste is trading one rooks is good enough
i'm taking on h three now g4 is under attack
if you take bishop takes at five can happen
uh teddy's handling as well and lars has a
minute and 10 seconds teddy is 41 seconds
so a lead on the clock for white but black is
up two pawns and it's white king that suddenly
looks like it's in far worse shape so black was
on the defensive now black is on the offensive
and up materials that's not a good combination
for lars and i would try to make a move like g5
just to go after this king somehow but it
could be a bit slow f6 if it helps me get
a discovery against your queen that should be
considered but f6 perhaps just rook takes f6
and then you're getting checkmate on the f1 square
so bishop c4 played clearing out space on the e
file maybe there's a quick little check meeting
attack but i can play my work to g8 my bishop to
d4 my queen to c3 all of these possibilities but
teddy takes in g4 and the evo does not like that
not one bit rook takes g7 is possible here that is
a distinct possibility and there is play because
king takes queen e7 check give me your rook with
check and your king's in trouble 23 seconds left
for teddy he needs to find a move here queen f3
looks safe but the problem is you trade queens as
bishop lands on e5 your king's caught in the
corner that's not so safe after all so gotta
move gotta move he takes bishop takes f5 what a
brave choice queen e5 there's queen f3 checkmate
okay so this king is in trouble this king is
in trouble i think that white's king looks like
it's in worse shape but where is the mate maybe
rook g5 and queen e5 or queen b2 kind of thing
rook chief i played but oh my goodness teddy finds
an instant wow and he gets we got a fist pump from
teddy we get a comeback time fist pump by teddy
let's look at that final position one more time
that was a really just crazy finish here rook
g5 it clears out the diagonal for a check but
after bishop e4 takes rook f1 bishop takes
queen takes bishop g1 that is check and mate
the bishop defense that king's caught in the
corner that would be a checkmate so we'll go
back to the new game here but teddy bounces back
with a win and now he gets the white pieces he
is down four to two this has been an up and down
match between these two it's been pretty level i
mean the score says what it says is clearly in
lars's favor but i feel like during the games
just the chess on the board has been both sides
with chances though lars has been quicker and
we'll see how that helps him as we go to the
quicker time controls but teddy the white piece
is now queen 22 nimzo and both sides playing a
bit slowly considering this is mainline theory
a3 if the bishop takes you take with the queen
here we go and typically black tries to strike
in the center with d5 and here lars goes
for the more solid approach d6 and that's
to play for pawn to e5 and only white has a
dark square bishop so if i can put my pawns
on dark squares your bishop doesn't have as
great a scope so it's different style it's
perfectly reasonable but if you played b4 bishop
b2 hoping to use diagonal well dick's knight can
come to d7 the spawn queen on e7 pawn e5 and
it's actually not as promising as it may seem
teddy energized now yeah teddy did seem pretty
pumped right that was a crazy finish and
these momentum ships really do happen
where you win one game where you're
on the edge the whole way and then you win and
you find a checkmate at the end you start feeling
rejuvenated you're like this is my match i can
handle this and there are just over four minutes
in this longest time patrol so we'll
see if teddy can get one more win and
uh if he can do that then he cuts the deficit
in half because he's down by two points
but lars going for the principal move e5 we
mention this pawn structure everything is
settled now d takes e5 here for black if you take
with the queen this bishop takes f6 and they get
a ruin your kingside pawn structure so that's
what take the pawn knight f3 simple development
now you need to defend your pawn e5 and knight
e4 is an idea at some point just not yet because
i'll take your queen and then you take my queen
but i take your rook at the end so 94 should be
thought about and it goes to show when there's
a pin and the piece that's being pinned to is
not a king the piece can still move and sometimes
moving it is actually quite good but just not yet
so sitting at thinking and if you castle maybe
94 is good because castle knight e4 takes
takes bishop takes check king h1 and this is a
good lesson in not stopping your calculation early
i have two pieces for a rook but where's my
knight going exactly oh that's right it's
not really going anywhere so i'm like rook to
e1 could just trap this knight in its place so
you know this is the kind of thing the kind of
tactics that these highly rated players they're
looking at they're trying to see it all the way
through but lars says i don't want to worry about
that let me just play h6 knight e4 maybe it's a
possibility in some universe just not this one
and bishop h4 teddy has to look out for pawn to
g5 and will we see some kind of sacrifice on g5
probably not so g5 bishop g3 knight to e4 yes
black has exposed his king somewhat by pushing
his pawns there but he forks the queen and the
bishop and lara says you know this is not your
game you can play g5 with a clear conscience if
i play g5 i'm gonna be worrying for the rest of
this one so let's play bishop f5 first develop the
piece connect the rooks to one another this pawn
a4 means that b4 there will be an amps on so you
can just press forward on the side of the board
and maybe i'll try to use it for my knight
it's a good square to get into and from white's
perspective maybe spawn a4 has gone too far
maybe later in the game i can attack it with a
bishop d1 or something like that and grab it so
teddy goes knight to d2 i think we understand
why he is covering the e4 square so that there
won't be a fork if this bishop has to go to g3
which makes g5 way less enticing i don't want
to play that anymore it just opens up my king
without any of the benefits of getting my knight
into the e4 square so lars sitting and thinking
teddy once again down almost a half minute on the
clock we've seen this pretty much throughout the
entire match where teddy is the one with less
time on the clock and for lars he is up f 42
should be happy about the chess he's played
thus far but when you lose one game especially
by getting checkmated you start feeling wait a
sec am i calculating that well am i doing the
right thing and so lars may be second guessing
himself and just checking this position deeply
and look at him he's just okay now i finally
shifted his gaze but before that he was just
staring at the board i don't know what part of the
board it was but that was intense he has a really
stair that just doesn't stop so lars
takes a swig calms down now he looks
chill so maybe he's going through the emotions
on camera for all of us here but you know it's
just a change in uh just how he's looking at
this position and well he's down 30 seconds
from up a half minute to down a half
minute without making a move on the
15 turn he plays bishop h7 which is a
move that he's a minute and a half for
but you're kind of like for what why did you
spend so much time on this move and that's not
to be overly critical of the guy he's playing good
chess and perhaps he just didn't see a better move
to make but these are the type of decisions
you need to make more quickly and i've been
pretty harsh in a way on teddy to this point
for doing that and now lars it's his turn where
he didn't need to spend all of that time and i do
this myself so it's kind of a do as i say now as i
do moment but he didn't need to waste all the time
playing bishop h7 the movie could have played in
30 seconds rather than a minute and 30
seconds so anyway the bishop's on h7
it's still on a great diagonal teddy doesn't have
a clear plan to work with f4 is like somewhat
tempting if you want to rip open the position
and try to get to this knight and pin it but f4
carries its own risk where after the pawn takes
now this queen is looking good on the e file so
f4 i'm still interested i'm looking at it but
i can understand why it would be a bad move in
fact rather than a good one so teddy now doing the
same thing if he plays rook a to d1 or something
like that you didn't need to spend all this time
playing rook rookie d1 or bishop f3 you don't need
to spend all this time but it's all right you
know maybe he's gonna take and put his bishop
on d5 or he's going to just take on c6 to give
block a compromised pawn structure over here
i would play some kind of rook to d a probably
rook f to d8 because my rook feels important for
taking the a4 pawn he choose the a rook and now
this is d3 square to use thanks this bishop on h7
so rook f to d1 makes some sense to me rook a
to d1 also makes sense rook d3 you know is what
black is aiming for so this is not out of the
question either bishop takes c6 just to hurt
the pawn structure and another reason why it'd be
better if this rook were here is this rook could
come to b8 and put pressure on the b2 pawn
and then this rook on f8 would already be on
d8 using the open line so the rook and f8 is kind
of not doing anything and he takes the c6 b takes
c6 you can throw in rook d3 that's possible
but i would have just taken on c6 as he does
and now lars is the men in the clock and teddy's
position is getting worse so he's going after
this e5 pawn i like that that's a hanging piece
rook e8 then i go rook to d1 and i don't have to
worry about his default rook d3 i say thank you
for your pawn e5 don't mind if i grab that one
so lars has a tough choice e4 knight d4 in the
c6 pawn and that shuts down your bishop so i
actually kind of like what teddy just did there i
see that the evaluation bar has gone slightly very
slightly in black's favor but in blitz chess
playing with double pawns is very difficult
i really feel that way that having pawns like
this is never fun having an isolated pawn here
isn't that great either do not play rook to d2
because you are walking to 94 at g5 first but 94
second and that's a fork so teddy now down to 57
seconds he made queen a5 relatively quickly a4 c7
e5 that queen is doing it all from the a5 square
attacking all these pawns b2 can be captured but
do you really want this pawn for this pawn maybe
the a pawn later in the game can become a runner
and that's not so fun so bishop f6 queen f6 queen
takes c7 is another idea i think just taking on a4
makes the most sense putting pressure on the next
pawn on c6 and teddy's 40 seconds left he's half
his opponent's time he's just got to make a move
just got to play in the flow of the position here
and the more you think oftentimes when you're in a
scramble you're you make the worst moves honestly
it's weird how that works but these players are so
strong that their intuitions are often correct and
he when bishop takes f6 the eval bar not a fan
of this decision and it frees the queen up which
puts pressure on this maybe there's going to be
some bishop e4 right immediately attacking darren
wow back rank check me i was like did i
just witness a really bad peace blunder
but if rookie five you can just check me in the
back ring queen eight is mate that's just mate
so that's why lars said i'm gonna put my bishop
on c2 teddy's knight to g4 tempo against your
queen this rook is still under attack so you
need to move the queen out of the way first
and where to queen g5 would trade the queens off
the board because your queen's under attack and
your rook is under attack over here but does black
want to trade queens seems reasonable with this
rook being very promising but this could be a rook
d2 at the end and that bishop is pinned so we're
getting far down the line here but that's how you
need to calculate you really need to think deeply
before trading queens and every move has its
consequences so lars deep in the think tank where
does the queen go g6 e7 okay e7 hits the a3 but
look at teddy he says my rook's under attack but
so is yours you can take the rook i'll take yours
you can take my knight i'll take your bishop so
this is what's happening here and he takes
we have this captain queen e4 going after two
pawns at once i said take my g4 pawn this a pawn i
talked about it earlier that's going to be a past
pawn for white whereas this king he lost one of
his defenders but maybe not the end of the world
here so it's a slight advantage for white it's
getting okay the queen does protect this i'm
watching out for blunders here we are getting to
that kind of time scramble h5 here comes h4 rook d
a check now what queen eight is there mate queen
eight and back here mate okay queen d1 please
take me i'll bring my rook behind my past pawn so
it's at h4 it's like can we trade him by rook d4
trading rook d4 the pawn ending is winning because
of this past pawn so teddy is able to steal pawn
and now he wants to keep this pawn if he can
not so easy so he's going to go check oh he
could throw them to check first check first and
then rook d7 was better because f7 would have
been hanging as well so teddy makes it slight and
accuracy he can play rook d3 rook c3 he's going
to do that king up king up this way bring the
king in e4 is fine but now the king can't even
come into c5 king d6 king c5 but candy takes their
c5 check i guess they're just in time to do that
so teddy is better here up a pawn and it's in
the past a pawn and he has pawns on both sides
of the board this is the flaw of double pawns is
white is essentially up two pawns in this position
if we think about it in terms of a king and pawn
end game so rook c3 back as possible plays it
this king wants to come to f1 can you get five oh
missed opportunity that king could have run right
into the g6 square it's still coming up the board
g5 the king over this rook d3 king g4 king h5 puts
his king here i'm not loving the way he's playing
it but his advantage is still a huge f6 you're
gonna trade by rook d3 or rook g3 like that take
the rook nice try cheeky move and lars his face
i thought he was doing it to be tricky but he just
didn't realize that his rook would be captured
after rook takes a3 and wow what an ending there
to this game to this time segment we finished
the five plus one time segment four to three lars
oscar how in the lead and for teddy you have to be
counting your blessings there you're like wow
i made it out only down one game after being
down three and for lars saying well i've had big
leads on the clock there's something going wrong
in some of these games and teddy is doing really
well in transitions in this game there was both
rooks were under attack all of a sudden pieces
started being traded and at like a certain moment
there teddy was able to figure out a way to trade
queens then offer the rook trade and see that the
king and pawning game would be winning so he did a
really nice job there lars to his credit he's been
doing well on the clock he's been outplaying
teddy in a number of different positions
as well so this match it's one game lead for lars
oscar have it feels like it's a true battle we'll
return a few minutes for more action from this i'm
not gm speeches champion match brought to you by
chess.com
so
and we return i'm pumped to be joined by my
partner in crime grand mastermind hamilton amman
it's a 4-3 lead right now for lars oscar hogg but
we're getting into the quicker time control so now
that we're here what would advice would you give
each player well uh first of all what's up robert
hello everybody bringing a new meaning to the
phrase better late than never so good to be here
and uh pumped for this match which is very close
right now teddy i mean keeping that score 4-3 um
you know as we concluded the five-minute portion
i think is already a a good sign for him going
forward i mean we we all know what kind of a beast
lars can be in the bullet portion but just to have
this match uh within reach right now i think if
you're teddy coleman you're feeling pretty good
yeah especially after being down four games to one
winning those last two games he must be gaining
some confidence feeling like he can do this thing
and now that we get into the three minutes a whole
different ball game and we just remind everybody
that this match will continue here with coleman
and how but let's remind everybody what happens on
tuesday because on tuesday night we'll be gotham
chess international master levi rosman taking
on eric rosen that's tuesday 6 p.m pacific time
amman i know we're not doing predictions for that
match yet we're still in the midst of this one
but any uh kind of thoughts about what we'll
see come tuesday yeah that that is sort of a
heavyweight streamer match up um you know i i
think there's gonna be a lot of very firm takes
you're not gonna say hey uh you know i just wanna
see a good match i think you're going to see a
lot of people very decided you know i want i love
you to win i want eric to win um but that's that's
going to be a pretty exciting matchup can i call
that one i'm not sure i can on paper i feel like
levy should be the favorite but um you know if
we've seen you know this match against james
canty for example um it all depends what kind
of shape you're in on match day that's true
and well match day is here and we have moves we
have f4 for the second time from lars and among
this bird's opening i said it doesn't it's not
seen very regularly it has its flaws and i think
that's one of them is if you get your bishop to c5
teddy last time puts bishop on d6 but these dark
squares on the king side can be vulnerable and
it's such a weird concept because in chess it's
like you play the bird as white it's like hang
on isn't this just a dutch with an extra move
it's it never makes sense to me almost that
i rack my brain i'm like wait why isn't this
good this should just be an opening that's
normal for black but with an extra move so i
don't know can you explain that phenomenon
robert i guess the dutch is just that bad
you even get an extra tempo and it's not doing you
any favors but look at this i mean it seems like
teddy's playing a straightforward game e5 coming
next the queen is on e2 here in harm's way i like
black's position yeah agreed um basically skipping
the c pawn um in teddy's position the pawn doesn't
need to be on c5 he's chosen to play knight c6
bishop c5 and it's not often that that normal
that you play knight c6 in front of the c pawn
uh in these structures so i like it you pointed
out he's going for a quick e5 and if e5 happens
keep in mind there's not going to be you know
mass captures followed by d4 forking because that
would be pinned to the queen and the king on the
e file wow an e4 talk about a move that i could
never play with my king in the center there wasn't
even a threat of pawn takes i don't think because
the e5 opening up would favor uh black there so uh
instead we see bishop g4 c3 that takes away the d4
square e5 remains a big possibility for black but
oman i see the eval bar how does black prove
the advantage here it's a great question
because honestly i think it can be very tricky
sometimes it requires a move like e5 but i was
actually going to say robert after the move e4
hitting the bishop maybe then it was time for e5
kind of a weird move but might be the only time
that you could have punched that in because now
see the difference you play e5 later f5 happens
and white's looking to kind of close things down
right and a5 play here but there must
have been something quicker maybe there's
a knight d4 sacrifice at some point because i'm
helped by that i see the eval bar going crazy so
there must be some tactic here and knight d4 just
taking back with the e pawn and going after the e4
maybe that's something uh what else can be played
here there's clearly a tactic now it's about
putting it together right yeah that that makes a
lot of sense i'm also looking at like bishop takes
f5 like if you force me to play something tactical
maybe i'm trying to play bishop f5 e4 just sort of
jam that pawn down your throat and bring the
knight to e5 because remember white can't castle
either so it's not like the very next move white
is just going to be safe right and easy for us to
say because we see that eval bar going crazy the
players have no idea and queen v8 triangle queen
a7 and this king still can't castle but now you
have to take on f3 he does so bishop takes back
and this king doesn't need a castle no king f1
king g2 and watch out for these pawns storming
for white on the king side yeah i i if this
hasn't already done this i can see this completely
turning around um because this looks like a g4
g5 as you mentioned uh pawn storm that i don't
see a good way out of i actually really like that
maneuver queen b8 queen a7 quite creative from
teddy but i kind of question like what the threats
are for for black and that's so annoying when you
play look at all the black's pieces on reasonable
squares including this queen and yet white has
this advantage because black has no plan at least
none yet and one of the deals here is this pawn on
c3 takes away such important squares from black's
pieces so how to continue maybe knight to b6 trade
off white's knight on c4 that could be an idea but
i just don't see an actual plan i see some moves
but nothing that says five moves down the line
this is what i like to see from black's point of
view yeah that's a good point and in blitz chess
i think what you brought up is exactly what makes
this so hard to play with the black pieces is
that having a plan first is not having a plan
usually the guy with a plan in bliss chess is
is gonna be happier queen a6 played adding some
pressure to the knight and you mentioned knight
b6 he might be intending it now that he can maybe
get the queens off uh you know with the same
idea yeah because these pawns do look menacing
where if a timely f6 or g6 the king on jake could
be in trouble so without the queens on the board
then there's no checkmating attack but white still
has the space black can't actually have a counter
shot that's the big problem i'm still looking at
knight d4 even though i know it shouldn't work i'm
that frustrated to have black's position here my
pieces are stuck yeah no it is super frustrating
you know keep in mind that structure because
pawn on c3 look at how much work it's doing
bishop on c5 knight on c6 none of these pieces
can join the action um and bishop e3 played okay
not a fan of that move at all robert i was looking
at knight d4 you know like you you went bishop e3
i was already talking about knight d4 so that p
sacrifice came with a little bit of but i get it
we're here knight can come to c5 now for teddy
and perhaps he should have played knight to c5
even before trading queens because then the
knight was coming d3 with check and there's
the b3 square and all this stuff is hanging but
yeah it's still knight to d5 for lars and he says
what's your night doing mine's better yeah i
mean you can't complain about a knight on d5
if you're lars in this position but keep in
mind even though we have traded queens that's
not necessarily the end of the attack i mean
you can still launch a pretty serious attack
uh without the queens on the board h4 h5 h6 um and
and that king is gonna be there's gonna be some
questions asked to that king and in the end game
there's gonna be some pretty dangerous pass bonds
uh for teddy to deal with absolutely and
that's why teddy brought his knight back to e7
and put his pawn on f6 and i don't want you
to start pushing your pawns the king is open
you made this point that the king is not fully
safe here you can't even bring your king to f7
because bishop h5 would be a very nasty check but
trading off rooks that feels like it helps black
yeah trades are good basically if i feel like if
he can solidify a position on the dark squares
here um a knight g8 yeah is the defensive move
this is where you almost wish you could play
checkers and go rook takes g8 and knight takes
f6 but that tactic is not going to exist and what
is teddy turning this game around a little bit
robert he just stole upon him so the a4 pawn not
the first time today we've seen teddy take that
pawn and now black is up upon white's trying to go
bishop c4 take on g8 so teddy says preemptively
let me go rook g7 pin your knight and h5 was a
big threat which is why the brookman's h2 yeah
you might laugh at the move rook h2 but um it's
a really good blitz move by lars he recognizes
peace trades especially the rooks uh is going to
be teddy's position is going to be super easy to
play after that and look at this teddy bring the
rook to d7 smart bring the king out of the corner
and now work g7 back if you want to you can just
bring your rook to that open line but there's no
threat for white you take over the c4 square by
playing your pawns to c6 to a4 in this chain and
now teddy's just taking over the board he is um
the knight is mobilized from g8 knight to c4
is going to be really good but careful about
knight c5 to e6 that is what lars is up to good
call because then the king is not saving knight
c5 rook g7 96 so you can't play for g7 you
have to rookie 7 but knight e6 was possible
that's the blunder you called it robert only place
that that knight could go oh and that's got to be
just heartbreaking because teddy was fending him
off but this has been a theme in the match time
trouble has done him in and that position he
was actually much much better and the eval bar
was saying pretty much winning for black yeah the
only thing about that game is uh i guess if you're
teddy you can't feel that bad because i i think
he'd be the first to admit that that was just not
the right game for him he he could have punched in
some tactics earlier but uh the way that game went
it actually felt like lars was in control for
most of it hit a really good position so uh you
know right when you got your chance at the end you
just had invested so much time to get there that
you couldn't capitalize and teddy clearly worked
on his response to the bird's opening during the
break because that happened once and now he puts
bishop on c5 rather than d6 if he gets another
break to look at that opening lars probably
would should not play that again because it was
saying minus two something like that there were
tactics flying that teddy couldn't quite work out
yeah and lars is going to know that it might be
safe to play in this three-minute portion because
hey you know the guy is stuck in
this match he doesn't have time to
go look at the evaluation bar himself and check
his analysis in that opening that's right and
so we get a more standard theoretical line in the
queen's game decline the knight went from b8 to d7
to f8 to e6 and now it's like wait okay it's here
what's going on the good news about this knight is
it helps for a c5 push and puts pressure on the d4
pawn because white wants to play f3 and eventually
e4 and get a big center and there's your push yeah
and f3 is usually an indicator to play the move
c5 because if you play c5 first you're still
going to get that isolated pawn but what the
black player wants to do is play c5 after f3 so
the pawn on e3 is always a target you say hey
you want to take me on c5 establish your isolated
pawn position is white be my guess but then then
you almost wish you could take the move f3
back so c5 is well timed there that's exactly
the case if you take then you also while you're
pressing the clock you push your pawn back to f2
because then your pawn structure is safe but with
the pawn e3 taking on c5 is actually very risky
and even if black takes on d4 and you take back
with the pawn you're not unhappy with this at
all your pieces are doing very well and the d5
pawn is about to mention that is there bishop f6
and knight takes d5 yeah there's um there's a move
that lars played he played uh h6 and uh usually
what i'm used to in this opening is that the
knight actually goes to g5 um so that could
have been a move that he maybe forgot or should
have played earlier it blocks that pin and then
if the bishop wants to trade for a knight it takes
on g5 so you don't get that f6 knight uh i think
you were right that that was a moment where
you could have just taken a free pawn i think
it looked like it to me and said teddy drops the
bishop back to f2 which we can't criticize too
much because he's protecting this e3 pawn and now
he's playing this isolated queen palm position his
rook is in the right place against the d5 pawn
and behind the queen so a movie e4 is probably
even possible here bishop f5 is a thematic idea he
says let's just play simple chess my rook can come
to d1 and i'll double against this pawn but the e3
pawn amman you mentioned it i'm looking at it it
feels like it's a sustained issue right yeah we're
we're all looking at the same uh pawn i am not a
fan of rook d2 rip d1 it feels a little congested
i think that maybe either knight b5 you know
movago or just knight d4 needs needs to have and
there it is knight to d4 and now if we capture we
both have iso the queen's pawns and can i capture
twice on d4 i know it's risky but the point is if
i take with the bishop and you take queen takes
is thankfully check to the king because otherwise
bishop h7 would turn the tables and the queen on
d4 would be hanging so i guess teddy would play
bishop h7 first and you take and then this
happens after some kind of capture yeah oh
i can't do that there's a queen on c2 i was like
wait why is the board not letting me do that yeah
that's uh would have been the case so this is the
type of idea which can happen in this position and
that's why lars said let me backtrack with
bishop to d7 and long story short i think
you're correct like that knight can be taken on
d4 but from teddy's perspective i don't think
he had another move sometimes you go knight d1 to
cover that pawn sometimes your bishop is not on d3
so you can you know move some piece to d3 to
defend e3 but the way the position was there
teddy simply didn't have another move to defend
the e-bomb so he probably said maybe knight d4
loses a pawn but hey it's my only option let's
play quickly yeah the thing is when you get rid
of that pawn your bishop on f2 which would have
landed on d4 comes to life so it was a very good
worthy pawn sacrifice for legitimate
compensation and lars didn't take it especially
look at his clock he's now down to 45 seconds
and that would have been way too easy for white
to play and difficult for him to play but
this position still remains hard for black
bishop f5 there's no direct threat e6 is defended
d7 defendant but every single decision like do i
take on d4 is that committing and helping white
in some regard he says no and we get this position
yeah um and pawn on d4 the thing with about these
rooks is that the reason i wouldn't necessarily
double them is because of what is about to happen
right now they don't look that good on the d-file
i mean hey that pawn's defended but the bishop
on f2 would be sufficient so i think it's just
sort of unnecessary firepower on the d-pawn and
you almost want to just shift them one file over
either to c or the e file so they could be on uh
you know somewhere with a little bit more scope
absolutely so the rooks are free to move d5
can't be captured because the rook will take
the queen and then this rook is hanging
on d2 with the bishop here as well but
sometimes you can get walk into a what looks like
a devastating pin but your knight can move but now
queen a5 is really good by lars here because if
he takes on c3 that's a backward pawn this knight
can come to b6 give me the c4 square i'm starting
to like black's position agreed uh i think that
uh that's a nice little maneuver uh queen a5
using the pin giving me a bishop for night the
knight is going to make an entrance on c4 i do
not think that there's any issues here for teddy
but i think it's the type of position that could
trend in uh you know black's direction here very
quickly just the knight against the bishop is
something that you have to be very conscious of
and teddy's h3 he says uh is that a pawn for me
or does he have some tactics planned he wants a
rookie check but the king hm queen b1 check that's
queen c2 which i think he probably overlooked
right and this looks powerful yeah now you have
to take and play rook to e7 at least you win back
uh one of your pawns because queen e1 that doesn't
look right that doesn't look right at all you drop
a2 f7 is hanging and some sort of bishop g3 oh
the bishop's hanging as well is there a perpetual
i don't think so the knight is too powerful it
takes the c8 square so you get a bunch of checks
but there should not be a perpetual yeah yeah and
always remember you know queen e6 king d8 queen d6
knight d7 the knight covers every single checking
square it's just a really thin we're about to see
it um there you go you can't check anywhere here
as as white no you cannot and what's the material
count it's a piece for just one pawn and this
a pawn is likely started gonna start pushing
and becoming a queen but still i don't think
black's fully out of the woods we know that
black should win this game but whenever your
king is susceptible to checks blunder's admin
yep that's a good point queen a8 um lots of plays
here queen f5 guards the pawn and threatens queen
takes f4 with checks makes a lot of sense there
and not that many pawns remain for black so
if you lose your a5 pawn that and especially
because you're both your a5 and b7 that's not
going to happen but then oh goes a5 that's
one yeah and now here come the checks again
yeah that knight is so powerful but uh
king f5 i think that's the right thing
so strong and then that's that right
this pawn is just pushing and okay
seven seconds for lars g4 you gotta start
pushing your pawns but it's too slow for
for white here can't play h4 you drop this pawn so
your pawns are stuck that's the killer that's the
killer you cannot touch the h pawn so all
the pawns are immobile and uh wow big big
result there as lars steals the the first couple
games here in the uh the three-minute portion
yeah and they've been really close
they've been nail biters but in that one
teddy i guess he didn't really sense the danger i
was complimenting him in the first time show for
his ability to recognize transitions of in this
case it was bishop taking that knight on c3 and
lars was the one who capitalized but in the five
minute it felt like teddy was the one who was
trading off simplifying in very powerful ways so
right now lars he's looking like he's in charge
of this match here and he goes back to his bird's
opening even if some of the games the positions
have been a bit shaky he says this is my trusty
weapon in blitz yeah and the thing about this
uh the way he's played this time uh his king's
not on e1 and he's not threatening a quick e4 so
um he hasn't put his queen on the e file
and his king's no longer an e file so now
e5 does fall victim to not only maybe
a loose bishop on f5 with the rook
but just taking and then following up with d4
which would be a fork right which did not work
when the queen was on e2 because the bishop would
be able to take but the man's point is good the
king is in the corner the queen is safe so this
kind of tactic would well backfire from black so
teddy's not going to play e5 that's for sure
if you play d4 which is somewhat tempting
you look at that bishop on g2 and it opens up
on the diagonal so d4 you break on the position
for your pieces but you really really helped
that bishop on g2 so i think that you have to
time that correctly if you play it at all yeah
and i'm starting to wonder i mean it looks like an
extremely good adjustment by lars for something in
the middle of a match uh in the middle of a format
the last time that he played this opening
didn't go that well and this one suddenly
looks a lot better it does but i'm looking at e5
he went queen e1 which makes e5 possible again
yeah the thing about e5 is you have to tell
yourself that your bishop on f5 being defended
only by the rook on e5 is somehow okay um and
teddy teddy's rationalized because we've been
pointing out that d4 doesn't work because bishop
takes right that queen being on e1 it's on the
wrong square you wish that if e5 happened your
queen could go back to d1 but the queen's here and
that's why chess can be a game of timing things
precisely and right now e5 is very good for the
rook it's winning that battle with a queen along
the lines e3 square especially if you take and the
e file opens up this knight can come to g4 later
i think that teddy's just pouncing and if you look
at lars he doesn't look very happy no no he's
he's barreling down with the calculations there
e5 i think you generally have to take
this pawn um after e5 but is he trying to
conduct a way to play like knight
h4 f5 trying to keep it closed
i guess and that does keep it closed uh but
then there's those d4 moves that we talked
about hey you called it knight h4 hitting
his bishop so where does the bishop go
yeah it almost like you know if you go bishop b6
the f5 move is too too tempting right it's just
gonna happen immediately um bishop g4 then h3
happens so i was actually almost gonna say this
but i i thought i'd let teddy do the honors
bishop to c8 what do you think of that move
i like it and i think you probably want to play
with like d4 now to open up the position for your
pieces and there he goes d4 is played but that
gives the e4 square and lars loves this style of
position where he can play g4 play g5 and that's
what he's going for even though it's not going to
happen maybe for the next five 10 moves but
this is the position where it's closed down
and he can go what he considers for like a free
attack on the king side yeah i don't know um if
this is the position that teddy wants because that
bishop on c8 it can't develop and the knight on d4
can always eventually be kicked out queen f2 c3
um and g4 g5 is such a quick easy plan for white
to initiate the bishop one e4 is a hero it stops
black from playing e4 which opens up the board
it covers the diagonal hits b7 protects d3
protects f5 and as we're saying g4 g5 but if
you play g4 maybe there's a quick knight to d5
and that hits the bishop gives you the f4 square
for your knight so you have to be careful about
these decisions and i didn't like taking that
bishop honestly because the rook on eight suddenly
it puts pressure on a2 but it also can maybe get
into the center of the board by lifting up the a
file yeah i think at some point lars is going to
have to invest into a move like a3 just to play it
uh the rook from a1 will swing over e1 or d1 and
we might see the move a3 right away actually
followed by maybe rook a to e1 and then he's gonna
try this king side stuff rook a4 i'm trying to
figure out is there at some point a threat of
rook takes e4 he says no not for now but bishop
takes b7 it doesn't attack the rook in the corner
so you can play c6 and trap the bishop
there so teddy quickly playing bishop c6
applying pressure on the e4 square this
seems like a good way to get out of things
yeah and if g4 happens there's always a long-term
idea okay we have to move the bishop but bishop c6
fell by knight d5 and then on d5 gets into f4 so i
was thinking something like g4 for white knight g2
to watch over the e3 and f4 squares um and
then h4 g5 just you know send send the uh
the king side pawns and well lars starts the queen
c2 to attack the rook on a4 so bishop c6 would
not have been possible because of the capture so
that's why teddy puts queen on a8 and is he lining
up some kind of bishop c6 if you take to take
with the pawn and then play c5 like is the queen
well placed yeah that's weird because if the king
was on g1 you could almost play bishop takes v7
f5 was hanging oh wow tay didn't notice the
difference like lars played the move and teddy
was responding instantly to bishop c6 he's
learning about you know his time trouble he
needs to play quickly but he could have taken the
pawn and now he's moving slowly again and his rook
take which is good keep the tension and maybe
go after this d3 pawn this looks good for black
agreed uh the rook is going to slide over we might
see queen e2 followed by rook d1 to watch over the
d-pawn white needs to do something but as soon
as g4 gets played that f4 square is looking juicy
that's true is teddy really trying to play c4 here
that seems not great if he's next e7 all right and
how does he continue queen b5 where are the pieces
going where do they belong i don't know i don't
know the rook on a4 looks so strange here it does
but the queen on b3 surprisingly a good defender
helping the king cause the queen can drop back to
f7 at any moment and 10 seconds for teddy he needs
to move yeah and he he knows that knight wants to
get to f4 but g4 g5 when the time pressure's on
that's the scariest thing to see and the thing is
the black king's in trouble right so knight takes
f6 check but then teddy may have a quick counter
against his king on g1 it just feels like white is
dominating right now because this is
such an important pawn in the position
agreed that's me that's such a strong move it
stops queen f7 really really good one there queen
h5 have to play rook g8 and king f2 wait that
king there's no checkmate for white and suddenly
this king is in trouble yeah and the rooks are
basically stopped by these connected pass bonds
in the middle of the board knight knight g6 with
tempo take this take uh the pawns are all falling
though but knight comes that f4 wow what is
happening here 94th check don't mind if i do okay
queen i don't know yeah exactly queen somewhere
we need the queen involved yeah h3 oh nicer is
coming i guess there's some sort of checkmates
you have to watch out for the bar is just
going up and down with every single move and queen
before checking h7 where's the wind king up to h6
oh that pin pin oh no pin is gonna seal it
just take it and if you want just make make
b4 a4 happen something like that you need to
pass upon there he goes he's going to play c5
and a4 wait so but if a4 you play c5 so here
come e4 now c5 win wait c by b5 what so a4
a4 wins you know a4 wins king d4 wait it didn't
like to just take and then black spawn queens too
and it's check oh my goodness oh my gosh check so
black is up a pawn and this king is super advanced
which should help an attack against this
king here what the heck just happened
both players have the same calculating
look right now the hands on the forehead
neither one of them can believe what the
hell is going on i mean i certainly can't and
queen e2 queen b1 check okay queen back to e4 i
like the queen on e4 the king yeah yeah exactly
what just happened oh my goodness bring the king
maybe the queen side yeah i i kind of like this
you want to try to push that pawn here we go king
c4 finally and now king c3 now if you just check
you block with the check those counter checks
are really important nice c5 here comes the pawn
c4 check on a3 king okay check your king
d3 king e3 just keep running the king away
you didn't push the pawn gosh the shield and
this kiss is really good by teddy yeah this
is very impressive play and now where is the
win feels like it's right there maybe i would
throw an h3 he does like it because this king
is in a mating net almost 23 and check when he's
that was amazing i did not i did not notice that
and that is exactly what you should be looking for
he missed queen d3 check but lars so so astute
how did he see that oh my gosh it's queen e3 it
takes away all of these squares and g2 is covered
so what a fine because queen d5 teddy had to play
check here which forced the queen trade wins the
game with his pawn instead he sees no squares
for my king and that is a stalemate trick if
i've seen one what a swindle at the end there
oh my goodness robert he the thing is he had
to play queen d5 what a wild wild game i mean
he there was queen d3 winning for black but
that's just uh full credit to lars and we saw
the little golf clap at the end by teddy he was
even appreciating um what his uh what his opponent
was able to do there well the player is going to
take a quick break they will try to wrap their
heads around what just happened we don't know but
we also will join them in that break we'll return
a few minutes for more in this three minute
plus one second increment time segment of this
matching international master teddy coleman
and international master lars ask for how
and we are back ready for more action in this
three minute plus one second increment time
control between teddy and lars amman that was a
wild final game we saw and just gotta give credit
to lars for spotting that stalemate trick yeah
and and i mean credit to both players that was
just a really exciting game because i thought
teddy was down and out i don't know how he
made a comeback i don't even know how he got
a queen on the board robert let's be clear
uh but both sides got a queen and then lars with
basically time taking down and i thought all hope
was lost he plays queen d1 initially i'm like
wait that's a mouse slip and no that is far from
a mouse slip that is a completely sick idea yeah
well done there by lars and you're right that he
actually has outplayed teddy in these structures
where the king side is frozen white has upon f5
he's been launching his pawns forward very well
but teddy kind of held him off well and then it
got wild had enough time so that game is sort of
the match some microcosm for the match at large
where things just get crazy and lars comes out on
top or in this case he survives a position that
as it wasn't going his way at that point
but really just credits both players for
the fight that we've seen yeah and we've seen a
lead uh as substantial as the one we currently
have so six and a half to three and a half
for lars but uh you know previously was 4-1
robert and and teddy mounted that comeback at the
end of the five minute portion however we're going
to need to see i think the exact same thing from
him in the uh in the three-minute portion right
now if he wants a chance in the bullet and lara's
going back to this kind of delayed benko's gambit
type of position and there's a knight on e2 which
may seem strange but if this knight does come to
g3 the e4 pawn is extra well defended so teddy
has a choice here he of course can take on a6
this bishop can take back and then we'll see a
bishop trade but the tension remains and this is
what we saw in the longest time patrol right and
uh i kind of like the the idea of uh this delayed
uh delayed benko i guess nate on g3 is never
the best piece against you know the g g6 pawn
uh can't really move anywhere it's mainly there to
defend the e pawn so uh i i think this is totally
fine for for lars and it's kind of an offbeat
opening that uh seems to play into his play
style a little bit more than teddy's it's gonna be
a wild game although i think teddy did study this
because in the earlier game his knight was on f3
and lars broke with e6 which he's doing once again
but the big difference is you can take on e6
and you feel good about your e4 pawn of course
the thing that black would try to do is play maybe
take with a pawn and play d5 but i'm worried about
these two pawns and teddy goes for right away and
i see the eval bar just sticks it says i hate that
it looks reasonable to me but look at this
this bishop that's a problem yeah yeah no
the movie e5 is such a natural move i want to
point out first of all like it's the first move
most people think of you want to ruin black's pawn
structure and take a look after d takes e5 that
would be a terrible structure like doubled
isolated e pawns isolated apon c pawn like
everything's a mess but the the style of the
position that lars has is is that you can take
a structure like that you can play an active
move like knight to d5 um and i think that this
is going to work out tactically for for lars and
lars is just he's wide-eyed he's like did this
really just happen teddy goes bishop c4 which i
think is a good decision all things considered
but he did it a bit more slowly than uh you know
i would want to do if i'm playing from the white
side here the bishop on c4 hits d5 it attacks
the e6 pawn perhaps with check behind it but now
i mean this e3 bishop can be captured i don't
really care about the e6 pawn g2 is hanging
it feels bad it does it does because knight takes
e3 it's like if you want to throw in bishop e6 as
a move in between i think you might regret that
g2 is going to be hanging and the only reason
i take g2 is that you can't castle uh ever right
you don't have an a1 rook and you're not gonna be
able to castle king side and on top of that e5 is
hanging queen h4 is coming up next queen e7 so i
i just i can see this going really really poorly
for for teddy yeah that e5 move we understand it
you regret it immediately and lars quickly says
hey that's a misstep there buddy and this bishop
on g7 very powerful as well the e5 pawn it can
take on d6 at some point or well not anymore
because i just took it but look at that the evil
bar dropped i'm guessing it's because it gives
white a little bit of time so teddy can castle
here if he wants and it's not that he's out of
the woods his position still is a bit difficult
but now is king of safe yeah no that's a really
important uh really important thing to have the uh
the king safe means that teddy can actually play
the rest of this game i was worried after knight
takes e3 f takes e3 that king would be stuck on e1
robert and just simply would never get castle for
the rest of the game and now it's safe and sound
if you do take on e3 i will certainly consider
taking e6 with check and queen a7 we saw sneaky
queen a7 in the match between costa and tanya
it's like well what queen a7 here makes a lot
of sense because i'm attacking your bishop putting
pressure on your knight and that's why lars just
says i'm going to develop and keep this tension in
the center with this knight on d5 and everything
staring at it yeah i mean you got these three
pawns in the middle of the board the bishop on e3
can always be taken and he started saying look if
you want to save that bishop go ahead uh you know
the knight's pretty strong on d5 i could take um
on e3 but i don't i don't need to you know i have
like ideas like knight f4 like queen h4 and the
knight on d7 might want to strengthen the center
by you know going let's say knight to b6 from
d7 and attacking the bishop at the same time
yeah those knights are very powerful and
bishop h6 gained a tempo against the rook
and lars says okay don't mind if i bring my rook
up the bad news about the rook being where it is
bishop takes e6 will pin and win that rook so
this knight and e4 is a bit stuck for the time
being but you mentioned knight two b6 coming
yeah and i think maybe like knight takes c3 and
queen h4 might have been a threat there hitting
the the bishop on c4 and the bishop on h6 so
i think the queen is going to come out to h4
like pretty soon or at least it looks like a
natural square but knight f4 is another really
really uh a good move aggressive move towards
the king although this is a great response
by teddy here he's keeping it complicated
bishop takes f4 is a threat because the e6 pawn
is not defended this queen on a1 is actually well
placed to jump into the queen side if you're not
careful maybe a5 some of that to pin the knight
on b6 and i think it's suddenly more difficult for
black to play even though i love this bishop on b7
and this knight and for what's the next move
here yeah that's a great point i think teddy
has a tremendous job in this game because i have
pretty much never liked his position uh the whole
way through and that's when it's hardest to play
good moves you mentioned queen a7 let's keep that
move in the back of our minds because queen a7
is going to really hurt lars's position at some
point if he's not careful and he plays knight
d5 which reinforces 994 which is necessary here
to defend his e6 pawn 12.9 seconds left for
lars teddy trying desperately to find a movie
is it knight g5 is it bishop g5 he plays h3 just
defending and lars quickly plays queen eight the
bar doesn't like that queen a5 taking advantage
of the queen moving so what's going on here amman
my goodness i i it's really really quick here um
i think we're just gonna have to appreciate the
the calculation that these guys are are putting
in uh kind of shuffling back and forth by lars and
every move by teddy seems to have purpose i really
like what he's doing so do i look the rook comes
in a7 the queen can come back to a5 and it feels
like largest position is on the verge of falling
apart yeah he's shuffling every single move by
lars is like queen his queen is moved like ten
times and the bar is just going it means that
black's position was fine at first but no longer
uh is it approved of here and what do
you do how do you break through for white
the moves that tay's making look reasonable and
i don't know that rook takes f7 queen a7 check
yeah okay but what's going on this
diagonal it's connect five no connect six
wait knight to e6 what's possible something
like that what's happening i have no idea
the b6 pawn is not quite hanging but after bishop
to e2 it might be yeah there it dropped and now
the queen has to go wait e4 is hanging wait
didn't take a free piece the 94 was hanging
this is too much to take in here it really is uh
knight after c5 knight c5 take on e5 you gotta
see these tactics yeah oh e5 is not that nice
bishop g4 is coming g2 is hanging here as well
and 10 times d6 pawn was just hanging there i mean
that's just the pawn was the least of the things
that were hanging in that time scramble robert
oh yeah that's those are just you know at the
end of them you're upset you're annoyed that
you lost the game but you just gotta be like
that was an utter crapshoot we both had
chances like spinning the roulette wheel
yeah it truly truly was and the the fact that
lars is able to win the roulette spins as well
as the ones where he's actually in control
is why this match looks like it's more out of hand
than it is yeah there was such a weird game e5 as
you're saying it looked logical but then it got
good for black very quickly but then teddy was
being resourceful and lars was shuffling but doing
so quickly and then lars somehow prevented teddy
from winning down the queen side and then finally
everything broke loose and until he lost in time
when lars did have the better position at that
point so oh yeah what is this by the way what are
we walking into now what's this pawns in g5 i have
no idea it looks awful i'm just gonna say like hey
straight up uh the pawn on g5 there's no bishop
on g7 the dark squares look really really weak um
i was gonna say is that a mouse slip but no
i guess it's not knight takes e4 and teddy is
uh going i honestly would have thought that
lars had the black pieces in this game because
this feels like a more offbeat line that he
would go for but said teddy's saying i'm down
by four points i gotta risk it to get some wins
here but now that lars has castles this rook is
staring down at f7 you can win upon c3 have fun
with that pawn your king is never gonna be safe
yeah i i it's very close to some sort of bishop
takes e6 queen over to h5 type of stuff um
the knight takes on f2 hey get rid of the bishop
but now the rook is actually ready to double up
as soon as that queen moves rook over to f1 i
mean i think there's just going to be a bunch
of sacrifices here how does black survive if
the knight goes to b6 to gain gain time and get
developed that just gives white to e5 square
and i i think this could be a really quick uh
win for for lars i am not liking teddy's position
at all no and bishop b5 played you mentioned the
e5 square he says don't mind if i hop the pony
right there real soon and i don't mind giving
up my bishop for this knight if it gives me this
e5 square so do you have to castle king's side i
say that but like this can't be right you know no
it can't be but it's it's a this is fine meme you
know just sometimes you got to go for it 95. oh
this is a disaster so if you castle short queen
h5 king g7 to defend h6 f7 is actually hanging
there which is a really like weird concept because
you're not used to the f file being open
this early um and uh rook f8 that's like
you know the beginner chess player that
tries to castle and touches the rook first
although he wants to cast a queen side so if
he gets one free move he will be able to run
his king to the other side of the board and we're
not rooked is rook takes f7 rook f7 queen h5 but
that's exactly it then you castle and get your
king to safety so there are tactics that look
powerful perhaps and i'm i'm casting right away
yeah i'm closing my eyes and castling go and the
c3 pawn is under attack yep and the whole thing
can fall apart queen takes c3 queen takes d4 uh
what is the thought process here yeah i was
going to say it must be queen take c3 otherwise
teddy is he wants the castle but i think
he's viewing queen takes e3 as an opportunity
yeah good inclusion it says my king is
never going to be truly sheltered so
at least i'm getting a pawn for my troubles once
i castle my rook is on d8 protecting my bishop
you can have the f7 pawn i don't really care
about that at this point as long as my king
feels safe and it will feel much
safer when you castle queenside
and i think rook takes f7 um is a consideration
here you can throw in that move to start um
because well he certainly can't take the rook back
and queen takes a1 there's like rook f1 check kind
of a weird move the queen on h5 delivers the check
and the rook then attacks the queen in the corner
so um there is a rick takes f7 consideration but
teddy can always seemingly just castle out of that
yes and this rook is hanging this pawn is hanging
with check bishop e8 is even a threat here to pin
the rook to the queens like all these tactics
could turn in black's favor and after rook d1
castle's queen side we see the evil bar saying
okay white is a bit better and that's typically
scary when whites down some material but knight
f7 then says nope not good it's funny because
i i don't even see how white's a bit better this
looks like it's falling apart and very shaky for
for lars and i don't know how teddy did that that
was a terrible opening but he might even be just
better now wait the rook's hanging uh i think
four i think you spoke a moment too soon there
because you want rook takes f2 queen c2 check oh
okay that's actually a good call and so knight d8
rook f2 king f2 queen takes c2 and this rook
is hanging right and there's like no way to to
stop it so bishop a4 very like intentional for
that tactic it looks like okay so where queen e2
was played and this rook can't go to e8 because
knight d6 check and if the rook goes to d7 still
knight d6 check and your rook is undefended
right yeah that's that is easy to overlook
that is very easy to overlook because you think
you're the one setting the traps you know getting
creative with bishop a4 if you're you're one step
ahead but this is actually such a weird position
that rook just can't move so you got to give it
up so i believe like bishop sees it by the e6
pawns also hanging with check that's annoying to
make king b8 i don't really know where else to go
and i want to put my bishop on c6 at the end
of the day so he takes an f7 rook takes f7 and
king b8 yeah so this is this is reasonable i think
if you were gonna do king b8 you start with it so
the rook's still on f2 in this position but not
not really a big deal because hey he plays rk
rock f2 himself so we're getting the position that
we wanted after all the bishop on c6 is powerful
but it doesn't threaten anything thanks to this
rook and f2 so i would just take this pawn he
does h6 is falling and teddy puts king on a7 so
he can take on d4 which was not possible move
ago because queen effect would have been a check
yep um i like what teddy did though king is safe
he's got a blockade and he can work on trying
to take the pawns you cannot let c4 d5 happen
um if that happens the game's over yeah it's an
extra exchange and it was one pawn now it's even
amount of pawns but this could actually turn
around let's say the coins get traded and this
a pawn starts running that is not the easiest
thing for white to deal with but when did d3
bishop b5 you were saying you can't allow c4d5
yeah stop it oof and this is gonna like i think
yeah i think i pretty much said it like c4d5
doesn't seem like a big deal but it kills that
bishop's diagonal and it was perched up nicely
now i think this is just over d67 you just
push it and the bishop will have to sacrifice
right yes rook takes c4 all right but d7 the
end still works you you've worked f7 to win he's
going to go rook back it needs to be rook c8 here
um it's definitely a valiant try because you can
play b4 and cover with the bishop so uh still
in this game and teddy's maybe two seconds they
both have two seconds i don't even realize that
now there are two pass pawns and whose pawns are
faster white is up in cereal this is crazy running
eight uh before before we gotta go 2.8 seconds
barely got that move off wow 2.6 to 1.5 two points
up again oh my gosh the king is going all the way
in black's going to win this oh no way bishop b5
wow what do you do here what is this who's winning
my goodness who's winning and why bishop c4 maybe
yeah bishop d3 okay bishop b1 is an idea to
take on h7 rookie my god what is happening
i have no idea queen but they i think the king is
in king f6 oh this also works you had a queen here
take on g2 may as well queen d4 check he's
got a flag oh my god they won a time and they
both are just laughing this is like the fifth
time in the match and someone is lost in time
he's going for the checkmate and he just loses
sight of the clock it's it's actually hilarious
because rook takes g2 and suddenly as white you
almost like you look around the board you're like
what the hell do i move here he's like panicking
he just literally could not pick up a piece
and decide where to put it in the amount of time
he had it's also a puzzle rush situation where
you know you're completely winning but you want to
win instantly because you're playing in this time
scramble so he looks like the checkmate and then
he doesn't find it and he's trying to figure out
what piece to move the rook or the queen and he
loses on time unbelievable unbelievable and lars
lars was looking after that like just
stunned like shell shocked he was just like
what the what that just happened like he
just got punched just in the face he's like
dazed and confused but he's gotta play the next
game right away so uh teddy he's gotta ride that
momentum robert if there's one way to come back
in this match it's wins like that that is just
bonkers and we get we get back to a position
where you see the pawn e3 pawn d4 dynamic and
the knights on g6 rather than an e6 so that frees
up the bishop on c8 but it doesn't put pressure in
the center so i actually like this position
better for teddy than i did the other one
yeah and keep in mind the pawn on h7 is different
from last time it used to be pawn h6 knight e6 now
the pawn is needed on h7 to guard the knight on g6
so um i would say though that teddy's position is
a lot more stable than last time and i would yeah
i was going to say i would take on c5 before black
has a chance to play c4 yes and well especially
with this b5 inclusion you create some weaknesses
and wait a second if you take on c5 can i move
my knight knight takes b5 and win your bishop
there that seems like a problem yeah because
keep in mind there's like ideas like knight c7
at the end of that um for example knight takes b5
bishop e3 knight c7 i think we win material there
right and he plays knight d4 which is a reasonable
choice but he wasn't thinking tactically and
just to go back a half step here you were saying
bishop e3 knight c7 that's a fork of the rooks
here and white winds material yeah that looks
great um bishop b6 and now lars i think i still
think teddy's position is is totally manageable
but look at the ideas for lars knight e5 brook c8
the c4 square the e3 pawn uh now i think this is
and i think the eval bar reflects it is a much
more even game after knight b5 wasn't played yes
and the bishop on f1 it's white's pieces are safe
the king is very safe over here but if you're
getting the feeling that white's playing a bit
passively defensively and when i see this dynamic
i want to play a4 but of course i can't do that
with the pin down the c file so a4 not possible
how do i get to your isolated pawn that's the
theme of this opening do i bring my knight to
e2 into f4 it looks kind of precarious honestly
but my e3 pawn is weak but there are times when
you bring the knight this way he plays bishop h4
losing side of the e3 pawn but gaining an attack
on the d5 pawn and the first thing that i would
think of is like i have to get my queen out of
the way so as white i want to move my queen it
just doesn't belong on a file where brooke is
staring it down so whether that is to make the
threat bishop takes f6 or knight takes d5 or both
um you know i'm going to need my queen out of the
way for that or just to just to move my queen so
that i can actually do something with that queen
i'm not sure from c2 it's the most operative there
is an idea maybe to throw it over to f2 and like
g3 um queen to b3 puts pressure on d5 so i would
look to get that queen out of the way even if
it's a move like queen b1 that makes sense and i
think a problem for white is you need your knight
in d4 but you also want it off of the d4 square
because if it's gone from d4 d5 is under attack
there are pins against this queen but you need
it on d4 precisely because of this e3 pawn and
it blockades the isolated pawn itself so bishop
takes you i like that decision that's a good move
to take that and especially when you take with
the rook you couldn't take with the d-pawn because
you're walking into discoveries against your queen
so the rook takes and that pawn is still here on
d5 as a permanent weakness yeah and it would be in
moments like this where i would start to punch in
um a lot of moves from white so brook d3 uh i
think it's very reasonable rook d1 i think moves
like king h1 h3 i feel like there's a lot of these
sort of wait waiting style moves that's right
because the queen is stuck on d8 you do not want
to allow bishop takes f6 we take with the pawn
this queen may be important defending the d5 pawn
there's bishop on e6 defending the d5 pawn so for
black i want to play a5 b4 but then my b5 pawn's
hanging so do i just play b4 no he goes back and
teddy's moves are easy yep yeah and this is
really important we've seen him come back on
the clock and look at that move king h8 he almost
wants to say maybe g takes f6 is gonna be a real
consideration in the future do you think he's
gonna be moving his queen to d6 or something and
being okay with those double pawns and it might
be an anticipation of queen h4 right because it
goes queen e7 and queen h4 still can be played
trying to take on f6 and double ship yeah oh wait
why would you take that did he just forget the
move bishop d8 was played because he's like what
why would you take that he's like well my bishop
now is here and that's all good so yeah this is
just i mean it's not a blunder but you know by
any stretch but it's just like a funny decision
to take you know bishop for night unprompted
especially when bishop d8 was you know the exact
counter that yeah and tennis position is still
good we like the rooks the pawn d5 is still a
problem maybe knight f4 now makes sense but he's
taking his time he's being deliberate but bishop
takes f6 that's a move you want to take back i
think so i think so um just no matter what he
will probably want that back um lars is gonna yeah
i was gonna say bring the king to the middle um
king to e7 and it's hard to add full pressure
to that what is he doing knight e2 maybe knight
c3 ideas but the counter attack comes with rook
c2 yeah the bishop on f6 right the bishop that
he gave up there and now it's playing its role
and b4 is a good move because a3 is a bit more
difficult to get to but bishop b2 could have been
played there it say takes on d2 and now you can't
get to this pawn and d5 is under attack yeah wow
this looks like a a miss if king d6 there's just
e4 or knight takes d5 and e4 um and you're just
going to pick off that pawn and so lars says
take me i'm going roxy too at the end of this
entice okay go rook c2 that's good for you brings
the rook back to d3 protects here but bishop b2
no bishop b2 walks into rookie too so bishop b2
will not be black's next move or it should not be
so white can you play f4 king f3 and get the pin
big fan of f4 the reason being that the king
is going to then access a light square which
stays off you know the dangerous uh dangerous
squares that could go through i think h3g4
makes a lot of sense here e4 loses immediately
in each form i'm not sure i'm a fan of that
and i'm definitely not a fan of that you
take with the pawn and the king comes in
that was just a really honest rook here robert
do you do you take with the right i think i
have a problem with the rock take with the
rook and you make a draw he does that yeah
rook d8 and just start going around after black
spawns yep seven seconds though and you gotta move
and he's probably frustrated as well black can
start you know after rook a8 go king d5 king c4
and just go for that win and he backtracks
the rook b6 is now rook b7 check and if the
king goes to g8 maybe there's an opportunity
somehow for white to play for moore and yeah
wait terrible move wait was it what uh that's
that's gonna be i think it's gonna be a win for
black now um still very drawish but it just
feels like decision after decision is not
going his way oh and he put his king here and
this pawn's hanging no this has been many many
incorrect decisions here yeah oh with a pre-move
the pre-move and lars just laughs and teddy can't
believe it well especially because in some ways
like rook takes f4 was the the easiest move to
anticipate from black so lars is probably like
hey you know you're not sneaking that one by me
um he takes that one that one back and robert what
a conclusion to the to the three minute portion
here because i i think we saw a sign of hope maybe
uh on teddy's side with that insane win on time
and lars winning the last game in the segment just
to you know make sure that things aren't getting
out of hand yeah and to make it matters worse
for teddy he was up a clean pawn in that end game
right he had an extra pod that bishop was the hero
for black the one that he ended up taking on f6
and then the bishop went to a1 and then took this
knight on d4 so some poor making there but also
it's tough you're in the middle of a battle you're
down three games you need to win you're putting
pressure on yourself and he did see that d5 pawn
is a permanent weakness so i get why he did it
unfortunately for him it didn't actually get him
the point and in fact he lost the game he really
had no business losing so for lars eight and
a half to four and f i'm on before we take a
break what advice can you give the players heading
into bullet well um for teddy basically uh play
a little bit outside your play style outside your
comfort zone make decisions you wouldn't normally
do look to play as fast as possible as loose as
possible and just know that you might have to
shift up your playstyle to get wins because you
need to make up a four-point difference i like
that advice we'll see if teddy heats it in the
meantime we're gonna take our last break and we
get to the bullet portion of this i'm not gonna
speed this championship match brought to you by
chess.com
and just want to remind everybody that you can get
involved you can play in arena kings season six
is well underway mondays and fridays anyone can
play only streamers can win but it's a fun time
you can play the likes of well-known grandmasters
other streamers who are you know making their
greatest efforts to take down those prize funds
it's been a lot of fun has it not yeah it really
has and i i was just thinking because uh hicaro is
playing in a tournament right now is this like is
this everyone's chance to maybe actually win first
place for once we'll see if he sits it out he is
playing in the champions chess tour but that's a
good point maybe now i'm more encouraged to play
honestly exactly there we go well before we get
to arena kings of course we have the final segment
of this match we have teddy coleman down four
points against lars oscar hogg you gave advice
you're saying what teddy needs to do he needs
to mix it up play quickly get positions that
are not expected and for lars honestly keep doing
what you've been doing you've been playing good
chess you've been finding the accurate moves in
time trouble and that's been i think the biggest
difference in this match is throughout the games
it's been back and forth but then we get to the
time scrambles and feels like lars has had the
upper hand but then again he did lose that game
on time a couple of games ago up a queen yeah it's
almost like uh both players are totally capable of
losing on time which is why i think that
teddy needs to be comfortable playing um
playing these crazy crazy positions and trusting
himself a little bit more that's what bullet's
all about instincts and uh we're gonna see if he
has what it takes robert in the bullet portion
because if he makes a comeback in this match
it's gotta be in the bullet portion which is not
where where i think teddy would normally expect
to score his points no the position is so closed
right now and bishop takes e5 you couldn't take
with the knight because the pawn would have taken
and said we're just getting a series of trades
c5 is on the agenda here i would push that get
my queen to b6 this feels like the type of
start to a game that teddy wants but lars
to his credit he's keeping things closed then
how do you win a game from the black side of this
yeah i was gonna say like not only is it maybe
a start that teddy wants it's definitely a start
that lars wants he's got two bishops i don't
really see a dangerous plan for black of course
there's lots of plans but there's nothing really
that he has to be concerned about so he can build
this up slowly um i don't think that lars is going
to be unhappy with what he's got in game one here
i guess in a sense i have my classical chess hat
on where like black is doing fine this is the
exact type of position you want you've neutralized
white's opening advantage but you're writing
bullet it's so frustrating this bishop on h2 just
sits here and covers the length of the diagonal
you attack my pawn on b2 i just protect it good
for you but i like this transition here if you can
get this knight to c4 maybe you can start causing
some problems for white yeah and that knight on d6
of course can be taken but i think lars is looking
to keep pieces on the board uh really like what
teddy's doing from a positional point of view but
keep in mind while you're playing everything on
the queen side uh h4 h5 and lars is striking on
the king side and that's why teddy brought the
queen back b5 wasn't really the main idea it was
allowed the queen access to the king side to help
out so queen f6 queen f5 offer a queen trade the
knight on c4 is very strong but time is taking
amman we've already spent two minutes on this game
and it looks like a position that will last at
least another couple agreed agreed um queen f5 is
a good idea and he's going to take that followed
by you know ideas like h5 ideas like b3 i think
this is exactly what lars is looking for although
from a tactical point of view if you can get e5 in
from black or maybe even g5 you feel like you're
making progress in the position the knight on
c4 is a great piece and type is rook a8 and a3
that's just it just hurts the little part of me
there robert when i see the move a3 basically
giving up on b3 as a move for the rest of the
game and teddy he plays rookie seven he wants
to open e5 i think you have to play three five
yep there it is there it is and the king can even
come to e6 just this knight protects and attacks
a great position for teddy with the black pieces
yeah and i think he's like tempted by
e4 here but he's worried about how he
wins the game after doing that because it's
hard to find a break right locking up the
position probably not great so he goes rook c8
trying to rook h8 and can i just win this pawn
okay now e4 ideas are attempting he does it he has
a pass pawn protected by another the knight on c4
dominates his bishop 1c1 so how to win this game
though that's the essential question right i think
i think it has to be g6 so the rook on d7 probably
rook d8 rook g8 or rook h8 followed by g6 that
makes sense you need to break open this position
because that's why look at this rook on f2 and f1
you cannot play g6 otherwise you drop this pawn so
maybe knight d6 would reroute the knight or rook
f1 oh he doesn't play it but this is great for
teddy he now has a of protecting and attacking g4
is falling so you can take it but then rook takes
f6 and rook takes f7 that'll be blunder he starts
with king e7 for that reason i think we just need
to guard the pawn um okay take on g4 is possible
now but i was thinking like 96 98 almost he just
trades right he says my past pawn is too strong
and if the rooks trade this game is over oh yeah
and even if the rook's on the board this knight
comes to c4 and the king is cut off ooh rook f6
great move yes well done here rook f2 e3 rookie
two it doesn't quite work so he checks the king
to hr rook g1 bring that rook around to b1 and
thank you for your b-pawn yep and keep in mind
that pass pawn is still going the distance oh no
that's a root blunder oh you got five we
continue to play the game are there still
chances for black here i think there's still
chances it's crazy black is better the evil bar
says black is better how is that oh my gosh e2
is coming what and then before taking knight c4
oh my god knight c2 would have been nuts wait he's
still in this game okay one rook one and it's just
not in time one move too slow you should resign
you gotta get the next game going oh my goodness
that's how dominant his position was he blundered
a full rook and he still he gave him an entire
room and was actually still winning that's
insane that's hard to do that is hard to do
and we get a new game here lars now up five points
and playing this kind of like dutch-like position
in the english we play pawns f5 and e4 and his
knight on h4 it'll continue to apply pressure on
this pawn on f5 yeah i was going to say after
d3 i've seen some lines where they take on d3
and you just go bishop g2 like you just or bishop
h3 like you're just going quick quick development
um so and i almost think you maybe need to play
in a little bit of that style uh maybe not that
move but that style because another game dropping
it's just it's not like you're one game away from
you know one game further away from the result you
want it's it's even more than that it's the time
invested in that game as well so he really has
some ground to make up definitely and the knight
comes back to gm lars is playing the most passive
position but he's like come on man beat me show me
that you can win this game and it looks terrible
for black this knight can come to d4 into c6 or e6
things like that if you take on d4 well then i
get the whole diagonal knight f4 knight d4 one
of these knights has to move into the position
but teddy's spending time and he only has just
under 19 minutes to catch up yeah i i really think
knight d4 from f3 was was the way to go you should
try to avoid trades a bit as um as teddy here
because lars does not have a lot of squares to put
his pieces i would go knight g5 and say take one
of my knights but then my bishop on b2 shines so
instead he doubles in the e file also looks good
but knight g5 is what i'm looking at and if knight
e4 are you uh considering sacking moving the queen
i'm surprised 84 hasn't been tried yet well it
might happen now just to close on the e file and
try to win this e6 pawn so not offend that bishop
takes f6 and knight to d4 protect your past pawn
put your knight here then i can come to b5 and
that rook is in danger on a7 yeah this bishop is
so strong at g2 knight b5 the rook has to go to a6
there's also knight c6 which forces the
blockader away i like that so knight c6 is
still probably good because you can't take on e6
there will be a bishop d5 at the end with a pin
yeah big fan if you want to play pizza oh knight
d3 okay maybe it's not a big deal um but knight d3
is there but now the queen will replace the knight
and it's hard to dislodge okay he finally plays
knight d3 yeah it's like it's about time and yet
white still has a pretty decent position but how
do you win this dude this is like the theme teddy
is look at that rook on a7 robert teddy's just
blundering material and still winning that's the
theme so how does he actually win this right like
yep i think you need to get your queen to d7
somehow like bishop b5 queen c6 queen d7 but i
don't think you have time to do that maybe i don't
know bishop d5 okay step one now but the c pawn
can move the rook is out of prison if he wants
to yeah and he takes that chance but he gives up
b6 and that's maybe not the most important pawn
but look at the time that's a bullet decision
though his work is free that's counter play
and look at the time it takes four seconds yeah
rookie three you have to and then rook d3 go
after this d6 pawn i feel like ted's position is
good but 3.8 seconds not a lot of time obviously
yeah black can try to set up a swindle here like
some sort of uh rookie like as soon as queen
f6 queen a1 happens man everything starts to
fall apart yeah the queen is an e7 like that's
the move you want to play we have the past pawn
so king h3 oh no he lost the pawn you need
that thing to win that's the one you needed
and it's still fine for teddy it's still good
it should be seven oh my gosh the rooks were
in like they couldn't defend each other but c6 is
pawn is still great he's still with c7 push that
thing push it keep pushing it still winning wait
no the other rook takes and the a1 queen my god
okay now he's losing actually but it should be
a draw um yes terrible result though because
this is going to be played on for a while just go
bishop e6 bishop f7 the king is actually caught
in the corner this game is going to continue
for another minute i would play g5 yeah exactly
okay i would actually play like 49 moves and then
play g5 but yeah to each their own yes and teddy
should throw in a g7 like if he anticipates
a pre-move and he's still not losing if he
plays g7 so the bullet thing to do is just play
g7 hope that lars is pre-moving on your queen
the problem with g7 is that um didn't they
repeat that position like 20 times by the way
the problem with g7 is that if you
play it and your opponent catches you
he's no longer going to give you a draw like if i
if i catch my opponent trying to get me with the
g set it's like okay hang on we're playing like
that well enjoy the next 150 moves of this game
that's right because the 50 move counter starts
again and then you make another pawn move
starts again and that's a problem so we do have
this um london type setup thingamabobber but then
f3 and g4 so it's like the juvenile london yep
exactly jabal london the the idea is a very quick
king side expansion and you know you play like
bishop d3 knight ge2 or nate h3 and then hits f4
right and if that knight gets to f4 that
bishop doesn't feel very comfortable even
on g3 it's strong you play h5 at any moment you
castle queenside that's what white's going for
but this is the type position you probably
are happy about if you're teddy because
you need to win games so at least absolutely
there's double-edged nature and c5 is coming
no this this is a good position to have for
the match situation you mentioned long castling
that's the idea but first e4 and taking the
space everywhere it seems like he's playing
in the center he's playing on the king side and
teddy does not want to castle on the king's side
so he castles long and this d4 pawn a long
term potential weakness knight b6 coming to c4
okay i pop that pony right into c4 because rook
d7 rick did he's playing this pretty well he is
i also like to move g5 for white um takes
take with the h pawn rook comes down to h7
and that g pawn just kind of annoying
and takes the f6 square away from black
yeah that's a good idea and knight a2 he wants
to go c3 to defend the pawn i still want to
play knight c4 but i understand the white queen
will then just run over the to the queen side so
knight c1 e5 not d5 don't like this now the
other knight goes to a7 first one a2 now a7
yeah because what's gonna happen is c4 that is
looking good knight d3 and i like white's position
yeah all of a sudden white's making progress but
the knight is the best one strange now oh an a6 oh
gosh you saw it coming yeah and i think uh e4
with defended knight is great blockading on d6 but
you know you're down material this is not this is
not enough no and queen d4 rook d2 nice move go
after the king side pawn somehow then he's going
after g4 and e4 still intense take that and take
with the pawn i think i take it yeah at this
point like queen g5 is the more positional move
but i think you just had to take with the pawn and
start pushing yeah take on e4 with the oh there's
yeah maybe you could take on e4 there yeah i would
take on e4 i would almost still take on e4 but 96
96 96. that's and that's a full rook by the way
and by the way i didn't look at this but lars's
bullet rate is 2800 and teddy's is under 2400 so
i think that going into the match both players
knew what would happen in bullet that lars is the
heavily favored player yeah and and that's why i
was saying when you're getting the bullet now you
know you're the underdog on paper you're also the
underdog in this match because you're down uh
going into this i think it was four games so you
really just had to play totally outside your your
style and comfort zone um if you wanted a chance
and that's what teddy's trying for he put his
bishop on the long diagonal but you don't want
to block the check with your bishop here and look
that's another check if queen e2 there's knight
takes d4 par probably so yep at least ideas
revolving around that so that's a bad thing
this is bad already teddy's got to move his king
to f1 i think that's no good and black castle so
lars i mean he's been impressive i have to say
that in the later portions of the three minute
and then now on the bullet he's really just said
i'm taking this match i am you know i threw away
a couple wins by losing a time you threw away
a couple wins by losing on time but ultimately
i feel like i've been playing good chess so let
me take this match and not even let you back in
it and credit to lars for sort of identifying
a win condition um he's done that in a bunch of
his matches so far he hasn't been like insanely
impressive in five minutes um but when it comes
down to the end of the three minute getting into
the bullet he really starts to turn on the jets
and he knows he's a very accomplished bullet
player that he can he can take home victories
in that portion alone that's true and he brings
his knight to h6 over here just saying no knight
g6 for you that could have been a problem for
the king on h8 but now the king walks away and
teddy's position he's still a pawn he has to take
on e8 and so he's up a pawn but the king on f1
that king is in trouble and it's because
the rook can't get in the game so easily
bishop e4 after g3 um it looks crushing
although do you have enough time to somehow yeah
knight f7 is strong that's
a problem very good move
got a sack for that you have the e6 square
for your knight but you're down in exchange so
and just like you know the the way that lars plays
bullet um he's up like 40 seconds it's insane
um teddy is just under tons and tons of pressure
game after game he is and lars has been great on
the clock with the exception being those couple
games that we've mentioned a number of times now
and teddy look at him he just planted a knight
on e6 and he's had his fair share of chances
right he yes even one as you said he blunders
and he's still better or still even he wanted
a full rook in that bullet game yeah that was that
was great that was basically the the the pinnacle
i think b4 by black needs to happen there was
queenie one check to take on f2 and that's why
right that's a good point so they brought
it it's always annoying eh when you when you
notice your opponent's tactic and you're like
oh man well that's not fair they didn't see it
right and this is still bad now no extra pawn
for white an extra exchange for black and time
is coming off the clock i think it's already too
late we're under 10 minutes yeah that's definitely
too late and lars six point lead is this match
gonna end with like an eight-point spread
it definitely could i think uh i think at this
point oh knight d3 a tricky guy yeah good effort
but drops another pawn rook f3 can happen or queen
f3 and he just wins on time yeah and he's i think
now is the reflection part of the the match
for teddy where he's probably thinking about
all those like miss chances and flags and just
things games he wishes he had back yeah you know
what i hope i hope we see just fun openings game
after game the match is already over so we have a
you know a king's gambit type of position here we
go g5 g3 trying to break open this pawn structure
and this is a fun one all right i'm happy about
this yep and we have the vienna uh it is a fun
opening so i think we're gonna be i think
we're gonna be treated to a good one here
uh the time actually is a lot closer let's look at
lars he's staying close to a minute on the clock
he's just in the flow he's on he understands
his positions very well whether it was those
games where he pushed us upon f4 in first
move and later to f5 close down the king side
and just put pressure on teddy or he has these
gambit openings where he's having a lot of fun
he has been doing very well in the clock yeah we
can take on g5 but i was going to say that lara's
move is to castle um don't even bother calculating
that castle king b1 knight d5 and start to start
to again feel that flow that bullet flow you
couldn't pay me that blocks position here you're
up a pod but you can't move anything you can't
move anything and like terrible d uh d5 knight d4
we know how these games go h5 then is under attack
e6 is mine f5 is mine and here it comes i think
he's about to do knight d4 and as you mentioned
he's going to trade those light square bishops
and that's going to open up all those light
squares like e6 f5 and everything for the taking
no fun none at all and you also will have a hard
time casting queen side because your king will
still be under attack once it gets there so lars
is under half a minute so is teddy about even the
clock but the position feels easier to play for
white it definitely does knight c4 though um seems
like a miss yeah it's the queen and the bishop was
under attack a second time you got to go knight c4
you really don't have any other moves yeah
because the king literally can't castle in
either direction so he goes king of seven it
just wasn't i mean now a second time yeah okay
both players are just completely overlooking that
possibility yeah yeah knight c okay there we go he
covered it yep and that probably when you see b3
happen when you're playing oh come on why'd you
play b3 because i had knight c4 exactly and now
lars is locking down the queen side and there's
a king on g6 which is not that unsafe but three
seconds e3 and then queen takes a4 for the fans
oh my gosh the bishop one d8 is just doing
a hero's piece of work here covering f6
covering c7 but it's also just terrible look
at teddy he's a rookie jade for a cage seven
he's like i don't care anymore maybe i'll play
h4 you know maybe he'll try to get a pass pawn
he's literally shuffled his
rooks for like every single move
that's great why did you just go king a3
pawn b4 trying to win on the queen side
yep the thing is the shuffling you know it
doesn't help the match clock it's not like
he's still thinking about winning the game of
course but just funny that lars is probably
like he maybe he's not checking the match clock
he's like oh what the hell i'll do this strategy
and well don goes g3 so who's king is gonna be
worse levels and the king of g6 is surprisingly
okay wait there's two rooks hitting the three
pawn wait none of eight let it be oh black guy
and does he see it he finds it yeah and he's
laughing at himself for like basically how
long that took yeah and teddy's just like what
can a guy do what can the guy do we still have
five minutes and so let's just have some fun in
the bullet i'm hoping for teddy's last game that
he plays knight f6 on move one and rook g8 on move
two that's what i'm looking for you think i think
i'm joking we might see it is that a is that a
teddy special it's not a teddy bear it's something
that i've wanted to try and i mentioned it to
teddy and so i think that if he you know is in
good spirits he's having a good time he might play
nine or six or g8 this feels like a good spirits
match like you know it's very competitive but once
both players kind of get in that zone where it's
out of hand i think it has been pretty uh good
good spirits uh the whole time you know even
some of the blenders we've seen it's almost like
both guys are kind of laughing at the blunder when
it happens on the board yeah when you you look
back on this match lars deserves to be the winner
based on what we've seen and for teddy it's like
well i was in most of these games and it's just a
couple things going my way it's much closer so
for both players there's a mutual respect here
and they're still playing some serious games
down the stretch this position here locked up
this bishop on g7 very happy the bishop one f4
not quite as powerful so i like black's position
yep b6 is gonna just say you know solidify the
entire queen side c5 square belongs to black
um you know white has some squares nate knight
on d4 and i don't d5 but i i agree i definitely
prefer lars's position and that a pawn is
going to be picked up and hang on you're
also threatening to win a piece bishop d4 yes the
bishop on e2 there was a forks on the b3 square
and now queen f6 you can win oh you can just
take on b2 right away i guess but had that
as a possibility so he didn't take this pawn that
was yeah maybe knight b3 to d4 um b6 is a again i
would take on that e3 honestly he does you don't
need to tell him twice the sacrifice material
yeah look at this bishop on e2 just such a bad
piece this night this is just good uh chess as
well like rookie three it's literally a rook for
a bishop but believe me in a classical chess game
some of the top grand masters in the world would
not only maybe consider that move but probably
play it it's good for black 94 in knight g3 check
and black is just better white has no moves you're
stuck nothing to do take on it i like knight g3
and queen oh you're that's you're an evil evil man
that's the way to do it e3 is hanging
b2 is hanging pick which one you want
this makes sense and bishop d4 is about to
win the game there it is that's game yep
so will teddy play knight f6 rook
g that's what i'm looking for
yeah this next game is his chance there's no way
he thinks of that at this time yes yes he will
have faith wait wait there's a trick like
b6 and then trying to to win here but it's
not going to work just you can take and then
rook takes bishop and your rook comes back to
defend oh nice try though if rook takes
the spawn takes b7 oh that was clever yeah
but now it's too much extra material with two
minutes of remaining the next game will be our
final one okay all right here it is here it is
here it is come on teddy made f6 for the fans
depends what lars plays one time all right teddy
do it oh [ __ ] it was so perfect for that oh it
was a prime situation oh i'm so disappointed
that's what i'm gonna bring up to him first
oh yeah forget everything it's like where was
knight f6 rook g8 you choked at the end man oh my
gosh i'm just so upset now if there wasn't such a
fun match to not end on the rook g8 note although
what's with the white's pawn structure now this
is pretty ugly with two sets of double pawns yeah
in the fact that e5 is not even your square like i
can play f6 and kick you straight out of there and
then the knight would have to go back to g4 so for
now it's you know f6 would be a problem with e6
square but it's an idea to kick that piece out for
sure instead voluntarily brings the knight back
so if i keep just sort of avoiding
trades if i give white a few free
it goes back to e5 well we did see a game where
teddy moved his rook like 25 times in a row true
and we saw the game where lars was defending where
he went like rook f7 rook d7 queen b8 like queen
back and forth so we've had a lot of shuffles
and isn't black just doing so well here he is but
uh g4 i was going to say expected g4 the funny
thing is f6 traps tonight then oh my gosh you
need the square for your knight yeah good call
yeah i would have played g4 and blunted my knight
there for sure it just makes sense you're
taking away the f5 square from the knight
and teddy playing some principal chess queen a5
off from the trade your pawn structure is better
knight to b8 where's that guy i would like
punch in knight g5 type of stuff and say
look you can win my night maybe with f6 but
i think it's almost time to sack because look
at the invasion on the queen side by teddy yeah
i'm with you i think that sacrificing was the
best chance for white because look at king h1 your
moves are just shuffling back and forth and teddy
bringing some more pressure knight to b5 comes
to mind to go to the c3 square potentially
play rook c8 and play c5 you don't want to
undouble the pawns but you can do so if you
gain something and g4 is g4 though i like it
i mean if you're going to try something this
is the right thing to do and all of a sudden
the e pawn and look how quickly the energy
just shifted away from the queen side right and
that's in very smart move rook to e3 protecting
this d3 pawn so that you didn't walk into
a loss knight c3 can you grab the a2 pawn
yeah but then then i think maybe f5 and counter
play look at that knight on e2 they're stuck
they're stuck your best move would be someone move
your first knight and then move your second one
out but the knights are trapped here and b5 you
said f5 there's knight five as well that could be
powerful because the rook is not defended look at
that i love that uh idea just give up the a2 pawn
and say look your knights are so silly they do
they support each other but neither one of them
can move yeah it's one of those situations
where it's quality rather than quantity
black is up a pond but look at the quality of the
pieces and oh my gosh this king is about to be in
a world of hurt look at those two knights black
king is probably like wait don't don't i have a
pair of those somewhere on the border yeah over
here buddy um b4 and a2 not really helping you
and knight takes up six yikes oh there's gonna
be some sort of puzzle rush finish here yeah
rookie seven queen h6 yep okay queen queen jade's
mate so now it's no longer made it's me queen
and teddy is just reacting like all the emotions
just you know came to fruition there at the end
and both players sigh of relief uh you know
i think both players are relieved that the
match is over they for sure are we'll hear their
thoughts in a few but ahmad just to summarize this
in the bullet it felt like it was about to
be a close match it had been to this point
and lars ran away with it so going forward for
him it feels like he has the right recipe to
keep winning these matches yeah it looked like
lars basically played the same opening with both
colors that is what happened today he played
the dutch and the white dutch so so that's all
he needed and he relied on his bullet skills and
at some point you know i feel like we were just
being treated to the lars show when he finished
with a 10 point differential one of the biggest
margins that we've seen in the entire competition
well we'll be back in a few we'll hear the players
thoughts in the meantime grab some popcorn and
we will hear from teddy and lars in just a few
so
and welcome back robert and myself are pleased to
be joined by the players from today's match that's
teddy coleman and lars oscar how welcome guys and
i'll start with you teddy i mean a rollercoaster
match in the end the score was reflective of a
pretty convincing victory by lars but is that
sort of how the match felt to you because from our
perspective there were a lot of really close games
yeah i i um you know i think definitely
there were a bunch of games that were kind
of pretty tight and and went okay until
we hit the time scramble and then i think
you know lars is just way too good at bullet and
and and playing under pressure and it felt like
nearly every single one broke his way and so you
know congratulations on the win it was uh it was
a lot of fun uh even though it you know didn't
quite go my way this time yeah and lars on your
end of things you were up four to one and then
teddy won two games in a row did that tilt you a
little bit did you feel a bit nervous or what was
going through your mind at that point uh yeah it
was a bit unfortunate because at first i thought
that like the match was going really well and then
after i lost those two games like the score is
almost even after after a three-point lead but
like i that i would do it better in the bullet
section so i just hope that i would do like fine
in the two blitz sections and then do well in the
bullets and i i got a lead after the blitz um the
blitz part which was great yeah that's a good a
good strategy and i guess one that you've been
using very effectively in the entire competition
uh teddy back to you because there were some
insane time scrambles you touched on them uh i
can think of a few off the top of my head where
robert and i were going crazy because you
you blundered like a whole rook and that
the evaluation bar was still in your favor uh
there was one game you blended a whole rook and
you had these pawns and a knight and we were like
just going going that so there are so many games
where i felt like you blundered yet you were still
in the game that's how good your positions were
yeah i think that maybe was the first bullet game
and like you know i played i think it was rook h2
and he could take and i was like oh my god um but
then i realized like my key my king was pretty far
advanced and i was like okay maybe there's some
way um but i couldn't you know i think again i
blundered a little bit later on and couldn't quite
hold it together but um no there definitely were
chances i just i just didn't seem to be able to
kind of capitalize on them yeah on the flip side
lars you found that stalemate trick at the end of
the three minute portion which was unbelievable
just recognizing that with no time on your clock
so between finding these tactical resources but
also we thought you played really well when you
would put your pawn from f4 to f5 and close the
king side so was that part of your match strategy
overall this kind of closed positions that allowed
you to go and try to attack um i generally try
to get like attacking positions so i don't really
mind if they're open or closed i just want a
position where i can attack and play actively
so um with the f4 f5 i thought it made it
easier to attack or at least maneuver for
some time and then his king might be weeks so at
some point but generally the strategy was just to
create attacking positions i didn't really
mind if they were open or closed yeah um
i think those are positions that's right yeah
i just think yeah those positions are also
just very easy for you to play because you just
kind of like throw the g pawn attack my king and
it's like a little bit hard for me to like
generate that um counter punch on the queen side
so yeah i think it was working really well for you
mm-hmm the like speaking of f4 f5 i guess was that
a match strategy lars that you were just going to
play the dutch like no matter what color you got
yeah but i've played a lot of birds on a lot of
dutch where i usually go for like this landing
ground uh positions but uh it worked very poorly
with black in this match like he played this d4
and then like early bishop g5 which i i ended up
struggling but i thought i got good positions when
i played it with white because then this early
bishop g4 isn't possible or it's not that good
at least yeah i had prepared this line with f3
which i only got to play once but uh you know
objectively speaking i don't think it's a very
good line but i think it just leads to kind of
interesting positions for blitz but i was hoping
to play it again but you never gave me a chance
yeah i i hadn't seen it before and you played
it so fast so i didn't want to repeat well teddy
speaking of questionable lines interesting for
blitz what about knight f6 followed by rook to
hit you had the perfect situation in the final
game i didn't go for it i know well at that point
you know uh i know that's your favorite line uh
to try to go d4 knight f6 c4 rook g8 but i saw
you know in the match against selena i think after
d4 knight f6 you were playing either bishop g5
or something like that and then you know then
i wouldn't be able to play it so i don't know
mass disappointment in the commentary booth robert
was livid that he didn't see rook g8 at the end
yeah uh wow but that was an entertaining match
uh lars you um congratulations it was a very
convincing win in the end uh in one of the biggest
margins we've seen um in the tournament and
you move on to the next round and uh you
know you you'll be facing off against uh
looks like roberto molina so uh any any thoughts
on that match upcoming have you seen any of his
previous matches in this tournament yeah i saw
his match versus lauren's trent that was quite
an interesting one like trent was ahead at the
beginning i think if i remember correctly yeah so
that was a very interesting match so i'll probably
have to prepare a bit for the movie in the arch
no seems like you're you seem pretty
tired right now i'm not gonna lie
do you feel exhausted after playing blitz
and bullet for three hours yeah yeah i do
honest answer yeah well we definitely appreciate
you both joining us lars congratulations teddy
sorry that your terms come to a close but
for the second consecutive year you made
your presence felt so you should uh hold your
head high thanks robert all right thanks guys
thank you and we will let lars get off the bed
it's probably pretty late there uh in norway and
we see that the bracket is filling itself out
lars oscar hogg moves on to face roberto molina
so amman based on what you've seen today based on
what we saw from roberto against lawrence who's
the favorite in that matchup wow it's a really
good question um such contrasting styles like
there's like maybe not a bigger style clash in the
whole tournament uh roberto molina uh when we were
commentating that match it's like can i trade
these queens off if so i'm doing it immediately
and lars is probably the exact opposite energy
so i'm really excited for that match up i think
that styles you know they say styles make fights
styles make matches so i'm i'm really excited for
that and also excited robert to find out
our our final uh our last semi-finalist
yeah we have the match-up tuesday night that
is 6 p.m pacific time that's 9 00 p.m eastern
if you're in europe you can do a quick little
google search to figure out what time that is
for you but you will not want to miss the matchup
on tuesday it is international master levy rosin
better known as gotham chess taking on
i am rosen that is eric rosen so i'm on
our time today for this match is done but you
know we've had so much fun today and of course
is ribbing teddy he is one of my best friends
for full disclosure teddy and i are super close
and we actually have talked jokingly in the past
i had thought about playing knight of six rook g8
so i was trying to you know pass the torch on to
him here he didn't do it but he uh you know he
played a tough match lars did seem like the better
player between the two in the blitz and throughout
the whole match lars was just digging deep when
he was in trouble and when he had the advantage
it felt like teddy couldn't find his footing so
i felt maybe 10 points is more than we expected
but it did feel like the match went heavily
in largest favor especially down the stretch
yeah and he's uh developing a recipe shall we say
for for victory because he's used a very similar
style he's he's using the clock to make up for
his bad positions which is a great strategy in
blitz you're not going to get a good position
every single game you play that's just not how
it works so he's making sure that when he's in
those tough spots he's playing quickly and then
he's using the clock as a weapon at the end of the
game to at least make a comeback and if you win
20 30 of the games that you're lost in and
you convert all the ones that you're ahead
and that kind of feels like that's how this match
went today yeah just that stalemate i'll never
forget that one yeah the quick queen d5 check
which should be paired by that queen block and
winning the game for teddy find that stalemate
with no time on your clock that's very difficult
because our instinct is just keep checking with
our queen and do something but not give it up
for free so that's of course that was a huge
moment in the match because teddy was trying to
uh decrease his deficit and all of a sudden lars
found the saving move it probably put teddy in a
bit of frustration and for large just throughout
i thought he played really really well so he moves
on the semifinals and well on behalf of us oman
i've had a pleasure with you it's been great to
see so many people here rooting on the players and
they'll have to wait until tuesday for more from
the i'm not gm speeches championship but they
can enjoy their sunday the super bowl's ahead
you're gonna watch uh i am gonna be watching uh
i'm gonna probably go and and host a uh a little
you know hype couple hour preview show uh you know
on the chest for all channel real quick but then
you know i i do have to end because i can't can't
be missing the super bowl as a as a north american
robert it's just it's a must watch well who do you
got winning uh it's not about who i got winning
it's who i bet on to win but i i i'm cheering
for i'm dreaming for brady in the box okay well
i'm rooney from homes of the chief so where maybe
partners for this co-commentary gigs but now we're
enemies when it comes to our rooting interests
but iman thanks so much again for having this call
with me today and to everybody watching please
have a good rest of your day stay safe and be well